Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du machst dich bereit äh ich haue demnächst die LNP NFTs raus.
Ey, wie wollen wir von fünf Blockchains gleichzeitig einen Rugpull machen?
Letzt Politik Nummer vierhundertundneunzehn vom was haben wir achtundzwanzigsten Januar ja genau achtundzwanzigster Januar zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Erste Zwölftel ist durch, dauert nicht mehr lang, ja. Ihr wisst.
Dann fangen die kleinen und so.
Goldenen zwanziger und Pandemie ist auch bald vorbei.
Viele andere gute Nachrichten haben wir. Es ist für euch auch noch genau, aber erst erst müssen wir noch euer Geld klauen.
Im Internet. Das können wir ganz gut. Das machen wir.
NFT.
Mhm.
Das macht jetzt jeder jeder schwache Mord und und und sein Freund sogar die blöde Transmediale es sich irgendwie nicht zu schade mit diesem Thema irgendwie äh aufzutauchen. Haben denn alle den Verstand verloren?
Haben die? Was machen die? Ich habe das ich ist lange her, dass ich auf der Transfiliale war.
Ja die haben dann halt auch so irgendwelche Künstler, die dann da so experimentelle NFT-Projekte machen und und ich habe ja auch so ein.
Hast du ein Experimenteller.
Das
dir auch alle nicht, wenn du dir die Webseiten durchliest, dann verstehst du ja sowieso nichts, was sie was was sie überhaupt wollen und verschärft sich einfach nur der Gedanke, wie bei allen anderen auch rund um dieses Thema.
Keiner checkt, was da überhaupt passiert. Aber alle wollen irgendwie dabei sein und die armen Künstler, für die ich ja wirklich,
Mitgefühl habe, ja, die eigentlich immer am Ende der Nahrungskette installiert sind. Haben dann so die Hoffnung so oh ja.
Meinst du doch oder? Also am Ende der.
Ach so, ja okay, wir gehen auch je nachdem, wie rum man die Pyramide dreht.
Ich habe grad so einen Pyramidenmodell irgendwie,
als letztes kommt. Auf jeden Fall äh du weißt schon was ich meine, ne? Das ähm
brotlose Kunst und jetzt äh laufen alle rum und versprechen ihnen irgendwie das goldene vom Himmel. Es ist einfach,
traurig äh mit anzusehen, wie grade da alles irgendwie durch.
Wie sollen die goldenen Zwanziger sonst finanziert werden? Hast du dir mal überlegt, wer die ganze Scheiße bezahlen soll.
Ja? Da braucht man erstmal noch ein paar Krypto-Scams.
Ja, okay, ja.
Unser unseren Gast vorstellen.
Ja genau. Äh wir sind nämlich nicht alleine heute. Wir sagen äh hallo zu Lilit. Lilit Wittmann, hallo.
Hey, danke, dass ich da sein darf.
Zeit gefunden hast.
Genau, herzlich willkommen bei Logbuchnetzpolitik. Äh wir müssen wahrscheinlich unseren höheren,
und Hörer nicht groß erklären, warum er dich eingeladen haben. Wir wollen heute äh unter anderem mal äh die schöne Geschichte vom Bundestags Telekommunikation weiter erzählen. Aber vielleicht auch noch das ein oder andere ähm Lustige, was so im letzten Jahr
passiert ist. Bevor wir das aber tun, räumen wir erst mal die Pflicht ab, ne? Äh Linus und kümmern uns ums Feedback.
Ja, wir äh genau, Feedback. Also ich habe letzte Woche tatsächlich das passiert,
wenn ich ehrlich sein soll öfter als ihr's merkt dass ich vergessen habe was zu erzählen und das hat,
Quengelfrieder bemängelt und sagt, finde es schade,
sie nicht über missbräuchlichen Daten abfragen von Luca Kontakt,
durch die Mainzer Polizei berichtet habt, zumal es noch weitere Versuche anderer Polizeidienststellen gab. Ja, habe ich habe ich wirklich einfach vergessen. Ähm,
es ging dabei darum, dass also in Mainz die Polizei ein äh Verbrechen oder eine Straftat äh untersuchen wollte und zu diesem Zwecke wissen wollte, wer sich,
zu dem Zeitpunkt an einer Lokalität befunden hat und da hat die Polizei sich quasi Amtshilfe über das Gesundheitsamt
geholt, hat das Gesundheitsamt dann Corona-Fall abfragen lassen und so ist dann die Polizei an diese Daten gekommen.
Aber das ist doch verboten.
Genau, es ist verboten, aber die Luca-App war ja sicher,
Ja der hat Luca hat dann natürlich groß erzählt, dass sie das verurteilt, dass ihr ihr sicheres System von der Polizei missbraucht,
so ja okay.
Und damit äh ging dann das äh Luka Domino weiter. Insgesamt ähm sind solche Fälle irgendwie über 100 Mal vorgekommen, wobei jetzt bei diesen über 100 Mal,
ähm eben auch Papierlisten oder Sonstiges ähm betroffen waren. Einer der vielen Gründe, warum wir immer wieder sagen, diese schönen,
anonymen Direktmeldungen, die mit der Corona-Warn-App möglich sind, ohne zentrale Datensammlung scheinen, überlegen zu sein, weil sie schneller stattfinden und keine,
derartigen Risiken haben. Auch das natürlich etwas worüber, wovor wir immer gewarnt haben. Na ja, dann,
haben wir ja letzte Woche ja schon das Luka-Domino ähm angekündigt, wenn ich jetzt grade auf Luca Fail schaue,
dann sehe ich nur noch Hamburg und Niedersachsen, die nicht,
debattieren auszusteigen. Das denke ich wird sich aber auch zeitnah klären,
insofern ja über die Hälfte der Länder. Es ist schon raus und ähm,
der die wenigen verbleibenden, denke ich, werden da auch fallen. Währenddessen hat Smudo jetzt angekündigt, in der Luca App soll dann das Impfregister sein.
Wo ich mir dachte, äh der arbeitet glaube ich auch gut daran, dass die App dann wirklich deinstalliert wird, weil ähm
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Impfregister so eine so eine Idee ist, die die Leute jetzt unbedingt in der Luca App abgebildet haben wollen ähm und viele Leute äh sowieso nicht.
Okay, also sorry, Quengelfrieder habe ich äh tatsächlich vergessen ähm,
ist hiermit nachgeholt. Ähm dann habe ich offenbar,
zum Thema Impfstatus äh was falsches gesagt. Da wurde ich an vielen Stellen korrigiert und zwar was jetzt genau mit einer Johnson und Johnson Impfung ist,
die jetzt einfach, zweifach, dreifach Booster oder sonst was,
Kommentiert mag, nur damit ihr eure Impfnachweis-Check-Apps richtig implementiert. Situation, wer zuerst mit Johnson und Johnson geimpft wurde, eins von eins und dann mit etwas anderem Zweit geimpft wurde.
Hat das je nach Impfstelle als zwei zwei oder drei 3 eingetragen bekommen, also zwei von zwei oder drei von 3 eingetragen bekommen,
Fakt wäre zum Beispiel in Niedersachsen, Baden-Württemberg oder Rheinland-Pfalz zusätzlich zur Erstimpfung mit Johnson Johnson eine zweite Spritze mit einem MRNA Impfstoff also BioNTech oder Moderna erhalten,
geboostert, Bayern beurteilt das anders. Hier sind zwei Auffrischungsimpfungen mit anderen Vacinen nötig, um
bei 2G-Plus-Veranstaltungen keinen zusätzlichen Testnachweis vorlegen zu müssen. Super, das heißt, es gibt jetzt also auch noch Unterschiede in den Ländern. Das bedeutet, wer nur zweimal geimpft wurde,
aber die zweite,
als drei drei eingetragen bekommen hat, gilt in Bayern als geboostert und muss keinen zusätzlichen Test vorweisen, wer entgegen zweimal geimpft wurde,
das als zwei von zwei eingetragen bekommen hat geht in Niedersachsen, Baden-Württemberg und Rheinland-Pfalz als geboostert aber in Bayern nicht, ist doch ganz einfach
Ähm Robert ähm.
Das ist für dich und.
Robert hat dann noch ergänzt zur Anzeige des XG-Status in der Kopfpass-Check-App. Leider ist die Logik hier noch komplizierter.
Als mit den verschiedenen Impfstoffkombinationen. Es gibt ja auch noch den genesenen Status und der ist auch noch zeitabhängig, wann, nach welcher Impfung war ich infiziert? Ich hatte mich zum Beispiel im November 1undzwanzig nach,
Astra Seneca und Biontech Kombinationsimpfung infiziert
Daher bin ich sowohl vollständig geimpft als auch genesen, erfülle also zwei G. Ich kann mich aber noch nicht boostern lassen. Das geht nämlich erst drei Monate nach der Infektion. Seit dem vergangenen Wochenende hat nun die bayerische Staatsregierung erklärt, hier in Bayern. Aber nur hier,
die juristisch die Durchbruchinfektion auch wie ein Booster zählen,
bis dahin und auch anderswo bräuchte ich noch einen Test um 2 G Plus zu erfüllen. Anders hätte es wohl ausgesehen, wenn ich die Infektion vor der zweiten Impfung gehabt hätte und was ist erst, wenn ich jetzt auch noch eine OmiCon,
draufsetzen würde. Aber ja, umso praktischer wäre es, wenn all diese komplizierten Ausfallbäume in ein offizielles Stück Software gegossen würden.
Das dann nach dem politischen Entscheidungen siehe Bayern einfach tagesaktuell gehalten werden müsste.
Es ist wirklich ein totales Drama.
Vor allem es ist ja auch äh
teilweise versucht ja die Software äh das auch sozusagen herauszufinden, was denn so dieser Status ist, indem es sich irgendwie alle Impfzertifikate anschaut, ne. Nur haben halt viele Leute grade am Anfang noch gar nicht mal unbedingt von allen ihren Impfungen so ein Zertifikat auch bekommen
und,
hier schon richtig äh kommentiert, ne teilweise eben auch mit sehr widersprüchlichen Informationen. Also es ist ähm ein großes Durcheinander.
Ja, das ist ein ein äh großes Hin und Her und wir kommen ja gleich noch mal zu dieser Impfzertifikats äh Geschichte. Vorher will ich aber noch ganz kurz äh den Kommentar des Provinz-Starter Staatsanwalts.
Wiedergeben.
Und zwar haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass das Zentrum für politische Schönheit wegen des Paragraphen 269.
Ähm Ärger hat und auf den sich eine äh die Hausdurchsuchung bei denen gestützt hat. Dazu ein paar Erklärungen Schrägstrich Anmerkungen,
Der Paragraf 269, auf den sich die Durchsuchung offenbar stützt, ist zwar etwas sperrig formuliert.
Meint aber Folgendes, unter Paragraf 2hundertneunundsechzig fallen vereinfacht gesagt Fälle, in denen Paragraph 267
Urkundenfälschung nur deshalb nicht passt, weil es nur Daten gibt, aber kein physisches Dokument.
Im Übrigen ist die Durchsuchung zwar in vielfacher Hinsicht außergewöhnlich,
Das liegt aber meiner Meinung nach vor allem daran, dass der zugrunde liegende Sachverhalt außergewöhnlich ist. Das Vorgehen der Polizei und des Staatsschutzes lässt sich meiner Meinung nach auch dann rational erklären,
man nicht unterstellt, die hätten das ZPS einfach nur schikanieren wollen. Näheres hier hat ein Twitter-Fread indem ihr das etwas länger auseinander nehmt. Deswegen überspringe ich den hier. Den findet ihr aber in den Shownotes.
Eins noch bisher ist ja leider nicht bekannt, wer das ZPS im Vorfeld juristisch beraten hat,
Daher an dieser Stelle, falls die Personen es lesen, unbekannterweise ein Kompliment. Zumindest nach dem, was hier bisher bekannt ist, kommt es mir so vor, als hätte sich da jemand auch juristisch kluge Gedanken gemacht.
Also.
Das will was heißen. So ein Lob mhm.
Dann hatten wir über äh YouTube äh DEL gesprochen. Äh da gab's auch zwei Kommentare und zwar einmal von Dominik.
Kleinere Ergänzungen zu YouTube DEL. Der YouTube-DMAintainer hat sich vor rund einem Monat selbst als inaktiv deklariert, vielleicht gar nicht so überraschend angesichts von allem. YTDLP
Das hatten wir auch besprochen. Ist damit der aktuelle und,
tief gepflegte Folg der Wahl. YouTube DE kann, konnte Videos tatsächlich nur langsamer herunterladen. Hier gibt es ein Issu of GITHUP, der fix, der das Problem lösen soll, kommt wiederum von YT DIP.
Und dann der wichtigere Teil als CL IT-Tool, also ist ja ein Command-Night-Tool, wird YouTube-DL wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht von vielen Endnutzern
äh Endnutzerinnen eingesetzt. Ein Problem aus Sicht der Copyright-Industrie dürfte sein, dass viele andere Tools darauf aufsetzen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel populäre Guisees, also grafische Programme und auch ich verwende zum Beispiel einen Webservice, der im Hintergrund YouTube DEL verwendet. Das Ding ist halt grade bei Entwicklerinnen beliebt,
Also vielleicht ein potenzieller YouTube-Downloader, Superspreader.
Mit an. Also er sagt, ja, das ist ein Commandine-Tool. Es gibt Browser-Plug-ins und äh andere Webservices und haste alles nicht gesehen, die das nutzen. Insofern, ja. Ähm quasi die Basis. Da ergänzt dann Thomas.
Dann die Empfehlung von Linus zu Browser Plugins zum Download ähm,
In Anbetracht der vielen schadhaften Plug-ins, die sich in diesem Umfeld tummeln, ist das möglicherweise gar kein so guter Rat. Äh also er,
das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, äh YouTube runterladen ist wahrscheinlich etwas, was viele Leute wollen und wenn sie da ähm nach äh nach Plug-In suchen,
sie wahrscheinlich potenziell auch welche eher zweifelhafter Genese. Gegen Vorschlag,
freie Instanzen oder selbstgehostete YouTube-Proxis wie Individues oder ähnliches
und ähnliche verweisen, wo neben dem Video bequem der Down,
angezeigt wird, um an sich alles als Web-Am runterladen,
eine Zeile FFM-Pack und schon hat man eine MP3. Macht weiter so. In zwei Monaten ist corona vorbei. Danke Thomas. Ähm da seid ihr schon mal zu zweit.
Siehst du, ne? Spricht sich rum.
Spritzt sich rum und dann hat er noch, fand ich noch einen sehr schönen Kommentar von danke,
Danke hat kommentiert ungelogen ohne Übertreibung. Es ist für mich jedes Mal wie Weihnachten. Wenn eine neue Podcast-Folge rauskommt, es macht unheimlich Spaß euch zuzuhören. Vielen Dank, macht weiter so,
bleibt gesund. Ja, danke werden wir tun. Das hat mich einfach mal gefreut. Ähm,
so auf Weihnachten, ist aber ungesund, achte auf deine Linie, nicht zu viel Süßigkeiten essen bitte.
Während während du den Podcast hörst.
Das war äh das das wichtige Feedback, was da so ein bisschen mal durch durchsprechen muss. Mit mit.
Mit Eigenlob sozusagen. Also bist du eingespielt ein.
Fremdlob.
Ja ja, na ja, Fremdlob zitieren und so. Das sind auch so.
Retweet ist doch auch schon das Lob auf Twitter oder so? Ja? Toll. Was? Ja, das kann ich ja richtig gut leiden. Aha, ja.
So läuft das. So läuft das im im Social. Sonst sonst hängst du da äh irgendwann, da musst du auch dir dein Geld schminken, muss hoch.
Fütterst du sozusagen deine ganzen deine ganzen geheimen irgendwie eigenen selbst betriebenen Fan-Accounts und so.
Ich weiß auch wie's ich weiß noch wie es läuft. Jut,
bringt uns äh zu dir Lilit. Ähm ist noch da?
Ich bin auch da, ja.
Das ist äh das ist gut. Hier läuft ja alles reimort. Da muss man sich ab und zu mal vergewissern.
Ja Mensch ähm erzähl doch mal ein bisschen vielleicht kurz äh was äh zu dir, wie bist du denn eigentlich so in den in den Hacker äh Kanal.
Und ins Chaos, Umfeld äh gelangt, dass du da jetzt so umtriebig dich äh aufhältst.
Also Chaos, Umfeld, ich glaube, das beginnt äh das begann so vor ziemlich genau zehn Jahren. Da war ich so Aktionsorientierte, jugendliche Hackerin.
Die sich so
mit vielen Gleichaltrigen über IRC und wie das damals noch so war ausgetauscht hat und wir haben uns zum ersten Mal in real life auf dem 28. C3 verabredet
und ähm ja keine Ahnung, da bin ich so ein bisschen in diese Chaos Bubble rein
rutscht ähm also oder war das erste Mal auf irgendeiner Chaosveranstaltung und dann
Na ja, ging das über die Jahre halt irgendwie immer so weiter und ähm obwohl ich dann irgendwann
Mit dem Aktionsorientierten Hacken so ein bisschen aufgehört habe und mich mehr so mit offenen Daten und so Krams beschäftigt hat, habe war das immer noch irgendwie so da und ähm,
Na ja, so,
2018 bin ich irgendwie zu diesem ganzen Thema Verwaltungs-Digitalisierung gekommen, mit dem ich mich ja bis heute noch super viel beschäftige, was irgendwie so passiert ist, dass ich,
irgendwann in so einem Start-up so,
H Capitalismus im Style so gefragt habe, warum die digitale die Verwaltung so kaputt ist. Das
entstand eigentlich so, wir denken drüber nach, was wir Sinnvolles machen können und dann,
uns damit ein paar Tage beschäftigt und dann habe ich gemerkt, ja Start-ups helfen da nicht, sondern man muss sich da irgendwie anders mit beschäftigen.
Dann kam Corona.
Und ähm es gab so eine staatliche Initiative, die heißt Workfood Germany, wo sie Leute, die irgendwie so Erfahrungen im Digitalbereich haben, für sechs Monate in ein Bundesministerium geschickt haben.
Und die haben mich so kurzfristig gefragt, ob ich Bock habe und dann habe ich gedacht, ja why not? Und äh ja dann war ich sechs Monate in einem Bundesministerium,
und ähm ja habe gesehen wie digital ditantisch jeder arbeiten.
In welchem Ministerium warst du?
Ich war im Bildungsministerium, in einem Grundsatzreferat für Digitalisierung und ähm ja, das hat halt richtig weh getan.
Was hat da was hat da also in welchem Maße hat das also ich meine es ist alles Mögliche vorstellen oder hast du mal so ein Beispiel?
Also da waren halt wirklich keine Menschen im Referat, die tatsächlich Kompetenz auf diesem Bereich haben, sondern dass,
waren halt erstmal alles irgendwie Leute, die irgendwie so generalistin der Verwaltungswissenschaften oder Politikwissenschaften waren und die haben halt irgendwie nicht so dieses Ding gehabt von ja wir beschäftigen uns jetzt selbst damit, was irgendwie sinnvoll ist, sondern.
Primäres Geschäft war irgendwie zu sagen, ja wir kennen da irgendjemanden und dem werfen wir Geld rüber oder äh ja wir haben hier diese Leitungsvorlage bekommen und ja wir verstehen die eigentlich nicht so ganz, aber das passt schon und äh also,
gerade zu Beginn von der Coronapandemie hätte man ja erwartet, dass so ein Bildungsministerium in so einem Grundsatzreferat irgendwie sagt, ja wir kümmern uns jetzt um die Digitalisierung der Bildung,
Na ja, wir sehen ja heute das Ergebnis so. Ähm da ist nicht viel passiert und ähm,
ich saß halt mit am Tisch, als sollte sich dazu entschieden haben, dass da nicht so viel passiert und das war halt ziemlich frustrierend und ähm ja äh nach,
fünfeinhalb sechs Monaten habe ich dann dazu auch mal ein bisschen mehr geschrieben, äh weil ich glaube, dass
Ganz vieles Problems, warum das halt nicht funktioniert. Einerseits natürlich, dass auf der Arbeitsebene keine,
da sind und andererseits natürlich die Struktur der Verwaltung selbst, die ja
die starke Hierarchie und so so ein bisschen darauf ausgelegt ist, dass am Ende des Tages äh zwischen Referatsebene und der eben auf der politischen Ebene möglichst wenig Durchlasseig ist und der Prozess möglichst langsam ist, dass es ja auch so ein
die Idee hinter der Bürokratie, dass es da einfach viele Schritte dazwischen gibt und ähm ja darüber habe ich dann mal geschrieben und danach haben sie mich nach fünfeinhalb Monaten rausgeworfen.
Weil du da so einen Nestbeschmutzer mäßig unterwegs warst oder wie?
Ja, weil ich zu kritisch, also weil ich kritisch darüber geschrieben habe, also wir waren's sogar dazu angehalten öffentlich darüber zu reden und zu schreiben. Das war irgendwie Teil der Idee, aber dass ich da irgendwie kritische Blogposts zu schreibe. Das war dann doch nicht so gern gesehen und da gab's dann auch so ein bisschen,
Kommunikations.
First Ruol of Bundesministerium. Very is a Bundesministerium und it's good.
Don't talk about Bundesministerium.
Ja okay gut, das kann das klingt ja äh schlimm. Also du meinst, es ist auch so schlimm da gewesen, wie wir uns das hier immer so vorstellen, wie es wie schlimm es eigentlich sein müsste, wenn man das Ergebnis sieht?
Ganz genau, also es ist es ist halt,
gar keine Kompetenz da und es ist genauso mit Lobby äh wie man sich das vorstellt. Die gehen da ein und aus und man freut sich über jedes Konzept, das den Leuten auf den Tisch gelegt wird.
Und ähm ja, also es war richtig richtig frustrierend und danach dachte ich so, ich muss mich damit mehr beschäftigen und ich meine, das war dann auch die Zeit als
all die Corona-Apps aufkam und all diese Sachen aufkamen und dann habe ich angefangen, mich damit mehr zu beschäftigen und
hat man immer auf Sachen geschaut und dann äh hat man gesehen, dass die irgendwie kaputt waren und so habe ich dann das letzte Jahr verbracht und mich ja viel auch mit tatsächlich Bildungskrams ähm aber auch so Sachen wie ID Wallet,
äh der CDU-App und so weiter und so fort beschäftigt.
Immer wieder kaputte Sachen gefunden und dann darüber geredet und irgendwie lesen die Leute das wohl ganz gerne.
Ähm,
Das mit der CDU-App, da muss ich nochmal äh reingrätschen also da wir hatten die Story ja hier auch erwähnt, äh dass es diese ähm App, die von der CDU intern ausgegeben wird, um quasi den Wahlkampf,
zu organisieren. Unter anderem nehme ich an, ne? Oder war das primär dafür gedacht?
Genau das war primär eine Wahlkampf
App. Also es ging darum, dass äh die CDU halt ihre Mitglieder besser aktivieren wollte, Straßenwahlkampf zu machen und die so ein bisschen zu nacken, dass die irgendwie mehr auf die Straße gehen, dass die irgendwie tracken, mit wie vielen Leuten an wie vielen Haustüren sie gesprochen haben.
Und dann natürlich auch Daten über diese Leute zu erfassen mit denen man an der Haustür geredet hat so dass man halt so
ein Stimmungsbild bekommt und andererseits natürlich die CDU-WahlkämpferInnen dazu motiviert, mehr zu machen, also so nach dem amerikanischen Vorbild von der Obama-Wahl zwanzig 13,
äh glaube ich ähm wo dir sowas ähnliches mit einer App gemacht haben und da dachte sich die CDU, ja das bauen wir einfach genauso nach.
Mhm. Und dann hast du das Ding ähm aufgemacht und festgestellt, dass alles voll voller Eier.
Ja, also ich konnte halt literally, indem ich ihn einmal,
so mit einem Lippenproxi in diese App reingeschaut habe, also sprich mir angeschaut habe, wie kommuniziert die App mit einem Server feststellen, dass man da einfach nur URL nehmen konnte, ein paar Parameter anhängen konnte und
hatte man auf einmal alle Daten aller CDU-Mitglieder, die sich in dieser App jemals registriert hatten. Ähm was halt irgendwie so
35000 waren, von denen waren aber wahrscheinlich die Hälfte irgendwie Spaß-Accounts, die mal die CDU-App ausprobieren wollten und die andere Hälfte tatsächlich Mitglieder und äh halt aber auch all die aller Hausbesuche, die die tatsächlich mal gemacht haben, was halt ein paar hunderttausend waren und,
waren halt einfach so quasi mehr oder weniger offen im Netz.
Und schon war es so äh das Hass äh äh Obje,
der der der CDU und die CDU hat natürlich das einzig Richtige gemacht und hat dann äh erstmal Strafanzeige gestellt gegen dich, weil du bist ja die böse Hackerin, die jetzt hier irgendwie die Daten verbreitet.
Das ähm wie ist das so bei dir? Wie gehst du damit so um? Also wenn du so machst ja sagen wir mal jetzt schon relativ.
Also du hast ja auch eine sag mal einen sehr offensiven Stil, den du so an den Tag äh äh,
Leakster. Trotzdem weiß ich nicht, ob einem das jetzt immer so so kalt lässt, meine so richtig geil ist das ja auch nicht, ne.
So eine Anzeige ist richtig richtig Scheiße
Also das ist eine richtig beschissene Situation, wenn man auf einmal so also in dem Fall war's tatsächlich eine E-Mail und kein Brief äh von der Polizei bekommen mit, hallo, teilen Sie uns doch mal bitte mit, wo wir Ihre Wohnung finden. Ähm,
Ja äh das also es war eine richtig doofe Situation und ich meine ich habe das gemacht, was ich immer in doofen Situationen mache. Ich habe darüber getwittert. Ähm und dann äh wurde das alles wieder deutlich besser,
aber es ist trotzdem immer noch so ein eine doofe Situation, weil man bezahlt erstmal viel Geld an einen Anwalt man hat irgendwie dieses Damoklesschwert über sich stehen morgen die Bullen in der Wohnung äh you never know what happens next so und,
ja, also das ist richtig, richtig scheiße. Ähm aber ja in dem Fall war's am Ende ja dann ganz okay.
Ja, weil die ganze Öffentlichkeit natürlich dann auch dazu beigetragen hat, dass auch die CDU einsehen musste, dass sie hier irgendwie komplett falsch liegt. Hat sich da eigentlich irgendwas gebessert mit dieser äh App? Kommt die noch so zum Einsatz? Ist das jetzt erst mal alles wieder zurückgezogen?
Also diese App existiert wieder im Store
und äh ich meine das richtig bemerkenswerte an der ganzen Story war ja ein Ende, dass das super viel Medienaufmerksamkeit bekommen hat und dann innerhalb von
wenigen Wochen, ich glaube so zwei, zweieinhalb, die Staatsanwaltschaft entschieden hat, dass die ganze Anzeige natürlich totaler Quatsch war und dass die Polizei Action immer jemanden gefunden haben, der Ahnung hat, der sich die Unterlagen angeschaut hat
und äh dann haben die das Verfahren halt irgendwie superschnell eingestellt und am Ende hat die CDU ja sogar die Anwaltskosten übernommen.
Dass ich äh zivilrechtlich gegen sie vorgehen musste.
Und ähm ja also ich meine am Ende war das alles ganz okay und diese App existiert wieder,
und die soll angeblich auch wieder zum Einsatz kommen,
habe jetzt aber nicht mehr nachgeschaut, ob das bei den also ob es seitdem noch mal Wahlen gab seit der Bundestagswahl, bei der Bundestagswahl kam sie nicht zum Einsatz,
aber angeblich soll sie wohl wieder zum Einsatz kommen und ich glaube aber, die anderen beiden Parteien, also die ÖVP und die CSU haben die App nicht wieder in den Store gestellt, also zumindest als ich das letzte Mal nachgeschaut habe, was jetzt auch schon wieder ein
bisschen her ist, weil das ja so eine White Label-Wahlkampf-App für konservative Parteien war, die aber von der CDU bezahlt wurde.
Ja, warten wir mal ab, bis mal wieder normale Wahlen in Österreich äh sind oder auch in Deutschland. Ich meine, mit Herrn Merz können wir uns da glaube ich noch auf so einiges einstellen.
Ähm dein deine Leidenschaft jetzt äh ist ausgerechnet mit der Verwaltungsstruktur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland aufzunehmen. Also das das den King müssen wir nochmal ein bisschen erklären, was wo
wo wo das jetzt eigentlich äh herkommt, weil das ist ja nun für die meisten Leute jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so das Erste, was man aufm Blatt Papier schreibt, wenn man,
fragt was, du musst sexy stuff ist, den man so kennt. Ähm was treibt dich da an.
Also ich finde das irgendwie gerade so faszinierend, was sich niemand damit auseinandersetzt. Also es ist so ein Thema, äh weißt du, wenn du das jemandem erzählst, sagt dir jeder so, ey, das ist ja total befeuert, sich stundenlang hinzusetzen und zu verstehen, wie die deutsche Verwaltung funktioniert.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist die Bundesverwaltung halt unglaublich einflussreich auf unsere gesamte Gesellschaft. Weil ich meine, da werden ja irgendwie Bundesgesetze am Ende des Tages geschrieben,
ähm da werden ganz ganz viele Sachen festgelegt, die uns am Ende alle irgendwann betreffen werden und trotzdem beschäftigen wir uns superwenig damit. Also,
häufig kommt es vor, dass du irgendwie Nachrichten liest und dann liest du irgendwie Details aus der Bundesverwaltung oder aus der Digitalisierung in der Bundesverwaltung.
Also wenn man wenn mal so ein richtiger Skandal ist, dann passiert das vielleicht, aber so wie die eigentlich funktioniert, wie da Gesetze entstehen, äh wie da grade Digitalisierung läuft. Das sind gefühlte Themen,
spielen sich in der Öffentlichkeit und den Medien viel zu wenig,
ich glaube, dass da aber halt ganz viel Quatsch passiert,
auf dem wir irgendwie als Zivilgesellschaft Einfluss nehmen müssen.
Das ist vor vor allem auch so so eine Blackbox, die einfach äh sagt, so nimm ich wie ich bin, auch wenn ich die erstmal noch nicht ganz klar äh erzähle, wie ich funktioniere und ähm finde das das ähm,
da ist mal für HK ethisch schon äh verpflichtet, sich das mal genauer anzuschauen aus einer ähnlichen Motivation heraus, habe ich mich auch so mit mit Steuern und äh Buchhaltung beschäftigt. Das ist ja auch so ein Thema, wo alle denken, so hast du keine anderen Hobbys
Ja? So, aber was äh äh was einem aber auch wirklich ähnliche Erkenntnisse bringt, ne, weil du einfach durch das Studium dieser,
angeblich so trockenen Materie, die in sich aber dann doch schon auch einen gewissen Reiz hat äh natürlich auch sehr viel darüber lernst, wie so ein Apparat funktioniert und wie er mit dir funktioniert und wie diese Machtverhältnisse sich letzten Endes dann auch konkret darin abbilden.
Tim, ich sag's dir trotzdem, mit dem Kind, ne, kannst du nicht auf andere Leute wie Lille zugehen und sagen, erklär mal dein Kind, den kann ich nicht verstehen. Wenn du.
Nicht gesagt, dass ich den nicht verstehe. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es an sich sozusagen für viele Leute schwer nachvollziehbar ist. Ich kandidiere das schon schon ganz gut nachvollzieht, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber man darf ja nicht immer von sich auf andere schließen, ne.
Ja und ich meine, was gerade daran halt so spannend ist, dass die Verwaltung ja Bundesverwaltung ja selbst irgendwie das
Bedürfnis hat, dass man eben möglichst wenig über sie weiß und das jahrelang, dass halt ganz viele Initiativen gab, dass wir halt irgendwie nicht verstehen, wie Gesetze entstehen. Und jetzt haben wir gefühlt so ein bisschen durch ganz viel,
Digitalisierung in der Bundesverwaltung und ganz viele andere Initiativen wie das äh wie das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Oft die Möglichkeit Sachen rauszufinden, von der die Bundesverwaltung noch gar nicht weiß, dass sie uns die mal gesagt hat. Und äh genau, das ist so,
so Sachen, obwohl man noch nicht so genau hingeschaut hat und die man auf einmal wunderbar analysieren kann. Und deswegen macht das richtig viel Spaß.
Du hast ja dann im Prinzip auch so ein ganz ganz altes CCC-Thema äh aufgegriffen, also schon wow äh Holland hat ja in seiner Zeit die Maschinen lesbare Regierung äh gefordert. Das war damals nach seiner Antwort auf den Maschinen lesbaren Personalausweis et cetera. Ähm,
den gläsernen Bürger sozusagen, ne, die gläserne Regierung äh zu schaffen. Und du hast dann angefangen, äh Software zu schreiben, die Daten einliest,
quasi also öffentlich verfügbare Strukturinformationen über über unseren Staat.
Genau, die Idee ist eigentlich grade, man nimmt alle Organigramme der Bundesverwaltung
und alle Haushaltsdaten und so weiter und so fort und baut erstmal ein großes Organigramm. Also momentan hat man ja irgendwie diese PDFs und äh da steht dann drauf, so ist dieses eine Haus strukturiert,
Aber wenn du jetzt jemanden erklären möchtest, wie die Struktur der gesamten Bundesverwaltung funktioniert, also welche Behörde ist welcher nachgeordnet und das ist irgendwie der Weg
diese und nachgeordnete Behörde an der Gesetzinitiative mitarbeitet. Das ist ja was, das kannst du heute niemandem erklären und da das ist nicht visualisiert und das ist in keiner Weise maschinenlesbar sowieso nicht,
und ähm
Idee ist quasi zu sagen, ja man baut einmal einen riesigen Baum, der quasi die gesamte Bundesverwaltung darstellt und am Ende hängt man da ganz viele andere öffentliche Daten wieder ran. Weil diese Referate
einzelnen Ministerien, die haben wir zu verschiedenen Zeiten mal eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetz,
Frage beantwortet und wenn man die dann daran hängt, dann kann man auf einmal,
Kommunikationssport mit zwischen Ministerien bauen. Ähm
oder man kann irgendwie rausfinden, mit was sich welches Referat beschäftigt, wer an welcher Gesetzesinitiative beteiligt war oder wie Geld verteilt wird, wie Lobbyisten mit mit den Ministerien interagieren und so weiter und so fort. Und das war so die Idee,
ich dann angefangen habe mir am Anfang erstmal die Liste aller Bundesbehörden anzuschauen, äh weil ich brauche natürlich erst mal eine Liste aller Behörden, bevor ich irgendwie anfange, die miteinander zu verknüpfen.
Und die gibt's ja dankenswerterweise irgendwie vom Bund auf Service Punkt Bund Punkt DE und die habe ich mir dann mal gezogen,
und bin einfach diese Liste durchgegangen und so bin ich dann zum Bundestages Telekommunikation gekommen.
Genau damit sind wir dann äh sozusagen bei dem Thema äh der Woche. Wir hatten ja letzte letzte letzte Woche,
das hier auch schon mal ausführlich äh dargestellt, was wir dann unternommen hast, dass du quasi bei dem Studium dieser ganzen Datenstrukturen einfach auf dieses ja Behörde oder Entität, ich weiß gar nicht was was so der generellste Begriff ist für irgendetwas, was es im Staat gibt
Auf jeden Fall diese Bundesservice
diese Kommunikation tauchte auf einmal auf und ist ja auch nicht ganz neu gewesen. Ist ja auch bei dieser Anfrage von frag den Staat von zwei,
20 11 war das.
2011 haben sie die Daten kopiert,
die haben das, was ich jetzt gerade gemacht hatte, haben die 2011 gemacht, dass sie irgendwie den kompletten Datensatz von Service Punkt DE genommen haben, einmal in ihre eigene Datenbank kopiert haben, weil fragt den Staat, braucht natürlich auch eine Behördenliste und die,
natürlich auch einfach vom Bund genommen
Da tauchte der Bundesservice schon mit derselben Beschreibung auf und die haben dann tatsächlich 2017 mal versucht vom Bundesservice Telekommunikation ein Organigramm zu bekommen. Dann ist aber die E-Mail-Adresse gebaut und dann haben sie sich das halt nicht mehr weiter angeschaut, weil sie halt dachten
Behörde existiert nicht mehr oder das war ein Fake-Eintrag oder was auch immer,
und äh genau deswegen ja hatten die das halt in ihrer Liste und hatten einmal diese Anfrage abgeschick,
die E-Mail-Adresse nicht funktioniert, aber genau.
Aber du hast jetzt sozusagen den Anspruch wirklich,
jede einzelne Behörde, also egal, was es gibt in diesem Stadt, jede Identität, die irgendwie ein Büro hat, wo äh Leute arbeiten willst du in deiner äh Datenstruktur verankert wissen.
Nicht Militärische.
Alles nicht Militärische, okay. Okay, vielleicht nachvollziehbar. Ähm hast du schon genug Feinde gemacht, ne?
Richtig und über die anderen prägt man nichts raus. Das ist richtig anstrengend. Ich habe das die ersten Tage versucht und dann versuchst du irgendwie so rauszubekommen, was diese eine Kompanie macht, aber
bei denen darfst du ja keine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen stellen und die schreiben auch ungern so genau ins Internet, was sie tun und was davon es wirklich noch gibt und was vielleicht auch wieder nur eine Tarnbehörde ist
Deswegen habe ich mir irgendwann gesagt, ja beim Verteidigungsministerium mit den nachgeordneten Behörden, die mich nur irgendwie zwei, drei, die nicht zur Bundeswehr gehören
aber sonst ist die Idee tatsächlich die ich glaube 280, 290Behörden und nachgeordneten Behörden und Stellen tatsächlich alle genauso aufzuführen.
Mhm. So und jetzt ist ja aber dieser Bundesservice Telekommunikation ist ja halt äh aufgefallen, weil ja, darüber sozusagen eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu zu holen war, ne.
Genau und ich hätte davon halt auch schon mal hören müssen. Ich meine, da habe ich mich irgendwie seit zwei Jahren mit der Bundesverwaltung und der Digitalisierung, der Bundesverwaltung auseinandergesetzt und auch vom Gefühl her mit den meisten Leuten, die da irgendwas machen, schon mal gequatscht.
Hätte halt irgendwann mal so eine Behörde mit so einer Beschreibung auftauchen müssen.
Und dann dachte ich so, ey ja da muss ich jetzt mal schon nachrecherchieren und nachdem wir auf Twitter, weil ihr wisst ja immer, wenn ich nicht weiterkomme, twittere ich, äh nichts sagen konnten
habe ich dann gedacht, äh jo, dann recherchiere ich jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr und äh das war dann quasi der erste Blockpost, über den ihr dann letzte Woche geredet habt.
Daraus hat sich ja dann schon so äh einiges äh ergeben. Auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Nervosität.
Im Bundesministerium des Inneren
ja in irgendeiner Form damit verbunden sein sollen, aber dann äh nicht bereit waren, das zuzugeben dieser äh diese merkwürdige Briefkastenadresse in Berlin,
Toe,
Aber irgendwie niemand zu bekommen ist, die E-Mail-Adresse hat nicht funktioniert. Solange bis du alle da mal äh dich drüber beschwert hast, dann funktionierte sie wieder. Das haben wir ja äh beschrieben und während also die Wikipedia dann erst mal eine Löschdiskussion äh führte, hat glaube ich
Thilo Jung dann noch mal äh nachgefragt so, weil in der Bundespressekonferenz und auch auch da rutschte man im Wesentlichen so von einer Arschbacke auf die andere und wollte so recht nichts sagen. Also Fischi war das ja sowieso und du hast ja auch so ein bisschen diesen Verdacht schon gehabt, so das könnte ja irgendwas Geheimes
äh sein und so eine Tarnorganisation, aber so richtig handfeste Informationen gab's nicht. So und wie ist jetzt diese Story dann weitergegangen?
Genau ähm also das Schöne war an der äh nach dem ersten Blogpost haben wir super viele Leute geschrieben ähm also ich,
habe irgendwann aufgehört zu zählen, aber es waren eine dreistellige Menge an Hinweisen, die ich bekommen habe von Leuten und
ist natürlich super nice, dass das so funktioniert und weil jeder hat mal irgendwie was gesehen und dann ist es auf sozialen Medien diskutiert worden und ganz viele Leute haben halt irgendwie Sachen erzählt und dann gab es ganz schnell so
habe da mal in der Nähe gearbeitet. Ich habe gehört, das ist der BND und so weiter und so fort, aber halt auch wenig Handfestes so
aber halt super viele Hinweise auf jeden Fall schon mal und das war dann irgendwie so, ich muss da jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen tiefer noch reinschauen
Und der erste Hinweis, der dann so richtig was gebracht hat, fahr, dass jemand auf dem äh Google Streetview-Bild aus 2008 das Firmenschild entziffern konnte
Das äh im äh in in der Scheibe hing äh zur Vermietung des Gebäudes. Und wenn man dann auf die Webseite dieses Vermieters gegangen ist, dann war da zwar,
Liegenschaft nicht wirklich aufgelistet, aber es gab eine Referenz, dass sie zweieinhalbtausend Quadratmeter in Berlin-Trip vermietet haben, diese Vermietungsfirma. Und äh an eine Bundesbehörde.
Und äh dann hat man sich die Liste Liegenschaften, dieses Vermietungsunternehmens angeschaut und hat irgendwie gesehen, ja sie haben mit Treptow nur ein Gebäude ähm und
wahrscheinlich das da und das hat sich dann am Ende auch durch so ein bisschen Nachfragen, Durchfragen rausgestellt, ja,
da tatsächlich zweieinhalbtausend Quadratmeter
an eine Bundesbehörde vermietet, äh wollen aber nicht so richtig sagen welche und damit war halt diese Theorie von da hängen irgendwie Briefkästen und die sind irgendwie da zum Spaß,
so ein bisschen aus der Welt und ähm na ja von da hat man dann so ein bisschen weiter recherchiert. Dann hat man erkannt, dass die immer schreiben, die haben irgendwie diese
Adresse in der Heidelberger Straße dreiundsechzig Slash vierundsechzig und dann habe ich mal überlegt, ja was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich mir da jetzt einen Internetanschluss der Telekom hinbestelle?
Bin ich auf die Telekom-Webseite gegangen und habe mal diese Adresse eingegeben und festgestellt, an der gibt es einen Glasfaseranschluss.
An der Adresse 62 und 5undsechzig, die irgendwie im selben Gebäudekomplex liegen, gibt's irgendwie VDSL fünfzig.
So eine Indikation dafür. Wahrscheinlich haben die da irgendwas hinge.
Alright. Aha.
Und äh ja, so ist man halt so Stück für Stück, Hinweis für Hinweis, irgendwie so ein bisschen weitergegangen.
Aber irgendwie nicht so richtig weitergekommen und ähm ich warte bis dahin noch nicht vor Ort in der Heidelberger Straße und dachte so, jetzt muss ich doch mal,
meine Höhle verlassen und rausgehen und quer durch Berlin fahren um mir das mal anzuschauen und äh na ja dann war ich da so ein bisschen vor Ort, habe mir irgendwie so,
alles angeschaut und was da so auffällig war, was mir vorher noch keiner berichtet hatte, war, dass halt, wenn man in die Tiefgarage reinschaut, da einfach so eine Reihe VW Sprinter stand, also so Transportermodell mit hinten sitzend,
halt nicht irgendwie einer
halt so eine ganze Reihe, also ich glaube so fünf, sechs äh Stück von denen und die sahen alle so aus, das wären die länger nicht gefahren worden, also sehr sauber für Winter.
Und alle dasselbe Schema an Kennzeichen irgendwie zwei unaussprechliche Buchstaben hintereinander, aber halt so
Also normalerweise also so, dass es nicht zufällig wirkte. Ähm und äh keine Ahnung.
Da überhaupt reingekommen? Also.
Äh das kann man so durchluten,
Also ähm ich habe dann auch mal geklingelt und bin dann vielleicht mal ins Gebäude gegangen und so und da hat man aber nicht super viel gesehen. Ähm ist ja ein also in dem Gebäude sitzen mehrere Parteien und äh der Bundesservice hat soweit, ich weiß, nur zwei Etagen.
Und sonst sitzen da halt so andere Firmen ähm so eine Abrechnungsfirma, eine Firma, die mal Glasfaserkabel konfektioniert hat ähm ja also so so ein bisschen Firmen, die auch alle so ein bisschen aussehen.
Eine Firma braucht Testroboter für Geldautomaten. Ich wusste nicht, dass es für so was Firmen gibt, aber Aparently gibt es die.
Und das war dann tatsächlich auch so als ich wieder zu Hause war der nächste Research-Punkt, dass ich mich so hingesetzt habe und ich habe mir all diese Firmen angeschaut, die in diesem gesamten Gebäudekomplex sitzen, weil ich dachte so, wenn da,
so eine Tarnbehörde sitzt, dann gibt's da vielleicht auch noch Tarnunternehmen, you never no.
Und äh dann bin ich jeder Einzelne dieser Firmen durchgegangen, habe irgendwie rausgefunden, wem gehören diese Firmen, wer ist Geschäftsführer? Wie sind die miteinander vernetzt und so weiter und so fort und der Witz, dass man konnte, weil jeder dieser Firmen irgendwas Scheys finden,
Ähm aber dann habe ich mal so überlegt, ist das nicht in Berlin eigentlich überall so?
Ähm und na ja, wenn man's überlegt, dass in so einem durchschnittlichen Bürogebäude in Berlin häufig halt einfach so einen Haufen Firmen sitzen, die irgendwie komische Sachen machen, weil ist halt Berlin.
Import Export irgendwas. Mhm.
Richtig oder ich mache irgendwas mit IT, aber ich erkläre auf der Webseite nicht so richtig, was es ist. Ist ja.
In Deutschland auch ein völlig normaler Zustand.
Ja genau und irgendwann gab es dann so den Punkt, da habe ich mir gesagt, ich höre jetzt auf tagelang irgendwie Firmen zu recherchieren.
Ich komme irgendwie ja hier nicht mehr weiter.
Und äh bin so ein bisschen weitere Hinweise durchgegangen und die nächste Sache, die äh mir jemand geschrieben hat, ist, ich soll doch mal so ein bisschen in die Datenbank schauen. Also die Vibe, die hat ja so irgendwie das
Grundbuch aller europäischen IP-Adressen, also verteilt IP-Adressen an Unternehmen in Europa und da kann man irgendwie zu jeder IP-Adresse beziehungsweise jedem IT-Adressblock irgendwie reinschreiben, wem gehört diese IP-Adresse oder wem ist die zugewiesen.
Und äh was ist die Adresse von der Person und der Ansprechpartner und,
war super super spannend, weil wenn man da nämlich nach der Heidelberger Straße gesucht hat ähm und nicht nach der exakten Adresse, sondern nur noch nach der Heidelberger Straße, dann hat man nämlich die Adresse
von dem BMI Treptow gefunden, also das Bundesministerium des inneren Treptow.
Also Treptow muss man noch mal dazu sagen, ist ein Stadtteil in Berlin, ja? Das äh haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht so klar äh.
Und zwar der, in dem sich die Halleberger Straße befindet.
Richtig. Genau und der Witz ist in Treptow. Da gibt es kein BMI.
In Treptow hat das BMI keinen Sitz und insbesondere nicht in der Heidelberger Straße aus seiner Heidelberger Straße 3und664. Da steht nämlich auf einem Briefkasten auch BMI drauf.
Neben dem Bundestags-Telekommunikation. Ähm aber es gibt sonst in Treptow keine Liegenschaft des BMI selbst, sondern nur von nachgeordneten Behörden.
Was nachgeordnete Behörden angeht ist das, es trägte und diese Gegend so quasi so eine Hochburg in Berlin. Also da sitzt irgendwie der Verfassungsschutz
dass das gemeinsame Terrorabwehrzentrum zwei Straßen weiter von der Heidelberger Straße sitzt. Auch der Berliner Verfassungsschutz mit einer Außenstelle.
Weiß gar nicht, was noch alles in der Gegend ist. Also Geheimdienste mögen diese Gegend.
Ja, das das stimmt, hm?
Sie ist auch wirklich auffällig, unauffällig so.
Bundeskriminalamt ist da auch noch. Mhm. Ja, beliebte Ecke.
Das ist auch von dem Haus nicht also wirklich nicht weit weg. Also es ist nicht nur in dem Stadtteil, sondern wir reden hier wirklich von so einem äh Block so, in dem sich das alles äh befindet. Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich alles da befindet, was du gerade aufgezählt hast, aber BKA und Verfassungsschutz, die sind da halt um die Ecke.
Genau äh BK sind irgendwie siebenhundert Meter oder so, also einmal ein bisschen die Straße runter und genau, das ist halt so alles auf der Ecke.
Das andere Interessante an diesem Eintrag in der Heidelberger Straße war die E-Mail-Adresse, die zu diesem Eintrag angegeben wurde. Ähm diese E-Mail-Adresse, das ist so eine typische Behörden-E-Mail-Adresse, die lautet Z 7undzwanzig.
Unterstrich eins at BMI minus Treptow Punkt Bund Punkt DE und
Na ja, das klingt jetzt glaube ich für Außenstehende so ein bisschen kryptisch, aber eigentlich ist das ja mit so E-Mail-Adressen in Behörden, wenn man einmal gecheckt hat, wie man sie
liest recht einfach. Äh das Z, da steht für Zentralabteilung und die zwei danach Unterabteilung zwei und dann das Referat sieben und mit Unterstrich eins dann das Postfach eins. Jetzt gibt's da aber einen Haken,
indem ihr gibt es kein Referat 7 in der Unterabteilung zwei in der Abteilung Z.
Es gibt nur eine Unterabteilung sechs. Ähm das bedeutet, wir haben da irgendwie eine E-Mail wieder eine E-Mail-Adresse, die nicht funktioniert
und so weit ich weiß, gab es auch kein Referat sieben in der Unterabteilung zwei in der Vergangenheit ähm und das war dann natürlich schon wieder so superkomisch, weil irgendwie,
E-Mail-Adressen, die nicht funktionieren und die es nicht gibt, hatten wir ja irgendwie schon beim Bundesservice Telekommunikation. Äh und das war dann natürlich doppelt auffällig.
Und äh das andere Auffällige war, dass die halt so eine Domain at BMI Minus Treptow Punkt bunt Punkt DE hatten und ähm,
alle Leute, die im BMI arbeiten und ich habe da echt einige gefragt, haben noch nie von dieser Art von E-Mail-Adresse gehört. Also jeder im BMI hat eine E-Mail-Adresse,
BMI Punkt Bund Punkt DE.
Also eine ganz klare Domain unter Domainstruktur, die halt auch im Prinzip die Struktur des,
Staates äh widerspiegelt, aber sowas wie BMI Strich Stadtteil in irgendeiner Stadt äh ist einfach generell nicht vorgesehen.
Genau, das gibt es nicht. Also im BMI, auch wenn man da im Mail-System gesucht hat, hat man diese E-Mail-Adresse nicht gefunden. Ähm,
und na ja ähm was tut man wenn man irgendwie komische Sachen beim Bund findet? Man schreibt dem Zertbund also sprich dem Computer Emergency Response Team des Bundes und sagt da mal Bescheid,
Ey Leute, schaut mal, ähm ich habe da irgendwie eine und eine E-Mail-Adresse gefunden. Die ist komisch. Diese E-Mail-Adresse hat tatsächlich auch funktioniert. Ähm aber die ist komisch,
und äh naja die Form äh zerbund wollten wir dann aber leider nicht mehr dazu sagen so. Also die haben gesagt ja danke für deinen Hinweis, das ist interessant,
Mehr können wir dir nicht sagen.
Mhm.
Ja und sonst sind die immer sehr sehr lieb und man kann immer über alle Sicherheitslücken, die man so findet, mit denen wunderbar reden. Und da dachte ich so, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwas sehr Interessantes.
Und dann dachte ich so, hm, nach BMI,
Bindestrich äh Stadtteil oder BMI statt. Da könnte man ja noch ein bisschen mehr in der Walddatenbank suchen und ähm relativ schnell bin ich dann auf das BMI Minus Köln Punkt Bund Punkt DE gestoßen.
Ähm,
Auch Köln ist eine Stadt, in der das BMI keinen Sitz hat und auch in den letzten zehn Jahren, soweit ich weiß, keinen Sitz hatte. Wer aber auch wieder in Köln sitzt, ist das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz.
Ähm.
Okay. Dann kommt einiges zusammen.
Ja, genau und.
Dann dachte ich irgendwie so, jetzt könnte ich auch mal nach dem Verfassungsschutz bei der Vibe suchen, aber die haben bestimmt keine IP-Adressen auf sich registriert. Das wäre ja,
recht offensichtlich. So was würde doch in Geheimdiensten nicht machen,
und habe äh ja nach verschiedenen Abkürzungen und Verfassungsschutz ausgeschrieben und so in der Vibe äh nach IP-Adressen, die ihnen zugewiesen sind gesucht und Bingo habe natürlich welche gefunden.
Und zwar einmal einen oder mehrere IP-Adressblöcke, die tatsächlich äh so aussehen, als wären sie irgendwie normale deutsche Telekom-Anschlüsse beim äh
Verfassungsschutz, also genauso wie der Eintrag was auch ein Telekom-Anschluss war, den wir in Treptow gefunden haben und ähm gleichzeitig aber auch Einträge, die äh auf das Straßburger Rechenzentrum von WLIANET zeigen.
Äh die haben die wunderschöne E-Mail-Adresse 3 A6 Unterstrich TKÜ at BFV Punkt Bund Punkt DE. Und wenn man da nachschaut, was es ist, ist es wahrscheinlich die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsteilung.
Im Verfassungsschutz.
Das ist die gängige Abkürzung TKÜ ja.
Richtest und das ist natürlich sehr witzig, dass man einfach so IP-Adress-Gruppen findet, die.
Für die Telekommunikationsüberwachung zugeordnet sind. Jetzt hoffe also jetzt hoffe ich einerseits, dass sie nicht so doof sind und diese IP-Adressen für Telekommunikationsüberwachung verwenden. Andererseits wäre es schon sehr witzig.
Und äh andererseits habe ich aber auch den normalen Telekom-Haus-Anschluss äh geben von äh dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz gefunden.
Neben dem Anschluss vom BMI Köln und wenn man,
die beiden Einträge vom BMI Köln und dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz nebeneinander liegt legt, dann hatten die wieder sehr viele Gemeinsamkeiten.
Hatten beide eine Poststelle at E-Mail Adresse
die hatten beide so so eine Namen als Ansprechsperson eingetragen, der so klang, als hätte sich jemand irgendwie deutsche Namen für 50-jährige ausgedacht, was beim Verfassungsschutz jetzt auch kein Zufall sein muss,
aber ähm und was eigentlich Spannende ist, sie hat einen Postfächer direkt nebeneinander. Ähm und zwar hat äh,
hat das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz ein Postfach mit der Nummer zehn null fünf dreiundfünfzig und ähm äh das BMI Köln ein Postfach mit der Nummer zehn null fünf sechsundzwanzig und na ja, die gingen halt
Also wenn es echte Postfächer sind direkt nebeneinander und das ist schon ein krasser Zufall, wenn es in einer Stadt kein BMI gibt, aber sie postfächer nebeneinander haben.
Das heißt, um das jetzt mal kurz eine Situation mal zusammenzufassen
Du hast ja sozusagen jetzt mal diese Gesamtmengelage, die Daten herangezogen und wir haben jetzt auf der einen Seite gibt es die Behauptung, es gibt einen
eine Niederlassung des BMI, mit diesem mit der obskuren Domain BMI Strich Treptow, die aber keiner kennt und und und von der keiner was weiß und die nirgendswo verzeichnet ist, aber die irgendwie,
da ist. So äh was es aber dann gibt, ist halt diese komische Bundesservice Telekommunikation, über die sich aber auch keiner so richtig äußern will, die äh aus den Daten, die du bisher gewonnen hast, aber irgendwie was mit dem BMI zu tun hat. So und.
An derselben Adresse ist wie das BMI-Trepto.
Genau und auch noch an der selben Adresse ist so. Und nach so einem vergleichbaren Pattern, wie das alles erscheint, gibt es auch ein BMI Köln in Köln, was wahrscheinlich da aber auch keiner kennt, wenn man nachfragt. Nehme ich mal an.
Ja äh wohl gibt es aber in diesen beiden Bereichen das äh den den Verfassungsschutz an die Niederlassung des Verfassungsschutz ähm.
In Treptowissmas konkret und in Köln ist es.
Wissen wir's auch.
Genau. Und das sind ja alles schon sehr witzige Zufälle. Ähm,
und äh na ja dann habe ich mir irgendwann gedacht, oh mein Gott, ich hasse zwar telefonieren, aber sowohl das BMI Köln als auch das BMI Trapto hatten in der äh Rybe eine Telefonnummer angegeben.
Und ähm na ja, dann habe ich gedacht, dass es jetzt zwei Uhr morgens das ist eine super Zeit, um da anzurufen.
Wieso wie so ein Dachs.
Ähm also,
Es war es war wirklich zwei Uhr morgens, als ich den Entschluss gefasst habe, ich komme an der Stelle nicht mehr weiter und andererseits dachte ich irgendwie so, also wenn die um zwei Uhr nachts rangehen, dann ist das verdammt verdächtig, weil kein Bundesministerium geht um zwei Uhr nachts ans Telefon.
Ja. Das stimmt. Um achtzehn Uhr schon nicht. Mhm.
Nee, genau. Also ich habe auch im PMI nachgefragt und sie haben keinen 24 Stunden Telefonservice für gar nichts.
Außer das BSI ähm mit seinem Zund, die haben einen 24 Stunden Telefonservice, gibt's das quasi in der Bundesverwaltung fast nicht.
Und dann rufe ich also ähm beim BMI Trepto zuerst an und dann klingelt es dreimal und dann nimmt ein Mann,
äh der wirkt relativ wach, leicht sexischer Akzent. Ich würde ihn so um die 50 schätzen und der meldet sich dann mit,
Michael Friedrich verspricht denn da und ähm also Michael Friedrich war der Name, der tatsächlich auch in der Vibe als Ansprechsperson stand und da dachte ich so,
und dann melde ich mich mit ja guten Abend, spreche ich hier mit dem Verfassungsschutz. Und.
Weil wie rufe ich sonst beim Verfassungsschutz? Also was fragt man da sonst, wenn man nachts um zwei Leute anruft? Natürlich muss ich irgendwie also gibt ja sonst keinen guten Grund. Also frage ich nach, ja frage ich mit dem Verfassungsschutz.
Wieso bist du denn gleich mit der Tür ins Haus und hast nicht erst mal gefragt, was er selber meint wer er sei.
Ähm das habe ich dann beim nächsten Telefonat gemacht.
Okay.
Nee, ich ich hatte mir vorher nicht so grob überlegt, was ich denn jetzt frage.
War so intuitive Strategie sozusagen.
Der Typ klang so wie als wäre er Verfassungsschutz und nachts um zwei, wie gesagt, ich hatte sogar das Gefühl, ich schaue einfach mal, wie er reagiert.
Er klang, er klang nach Verfassungsschutz. Okay, wie klingt man denn, wenn man nach Verfassungsschutz klingt?
Äh sächsisch um die 50. nachts um 2 wach.
Also alle Sachsen, die um die 50 sind und nachts um zwei noch wach, ihr seid verdächtig.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall mein Bild. Ähm.
Mhm. Aber nur wenn man ans Telefon geht und zwar ist man natürlich normalerweise nicht machen, ne.
Nee. Und dann hat er sich hat er sich zurückgemeldet mit äh ja, wer sind Sie denn und äh was wollen Sie denn und er wirkt sehr sehr unruhig. Und ähm.
Habe ich mich halt da habe ich mich natürlich vorgestellt. Mein Name ist Lilit Wittmann und ich habe ein paar kurze Fragen äh an sie Herr äh Friedrich äh und aber ich musste erst wissen, ob ich mit dem Verfassungsschutz spreche.
Und dann war er auf einmal sehr gefast und meinte so, nein, nein, sie sprechen mit Michael Friedrich, ich glaube, sie haben sich verwählt.
Und dann ging das ein bisschen hin und her und dann meinte ich irgendwann auch mal so, also aber ich spreche jetzt nicht mit dem Verfassungsschutz, habe ich sie richtig verstanden
und dann war er so, aber doch nicht nachts um zwei. Was wollen Sie denn jetzt eigentlich von mir?
Meinte ich so, ja, aber ich habe Ihnen auch jetzt eine Frage gestellt. Ich hatte Ihre Telefonnummer im Kontext, das,
Treptow gefunden und da wollte ich von ihnen wissen
Ob's jetzt eine Tarnbehörde des Verfassungsschutz oder so was das sind oder was ist denn das BMI-Trepum? Und das ging dann auch so ein bisschen hin und her und irgendwann sagte er jetzt so, ja ja, wir hören jetzt auf zu reden und,
gelegt. Und na aber es war halt sehr auffällig, weil er war super wach nachts um zwei, war sofort am Telefon.
Und ähm ja dann hat er aber aufgelegt und danach war die Telefonnummer nie wieder zu erreichen. Ähm,
und was äh noch ganz witzig war in dem Kontext, ich wollte ihm danach noch eine E-Mail schreiben, weil ich noch mehr Fragen an ihn hatte und er war ja nicht mehr zu erreichen
Und da dachte ich so, wie sehen denn E-Mail-Adressen in Behörden aus? Meistens Vorname Punkt Nachname.
Also habe ich eine E-Mail-Adresse an Michael Punkt Friedrich und dann einmal at BST Punkt Bund DE für den Bundesservice Telekommunikation an BMI Minus Köln Punkt DE an äh dem I Minus Tretro Punkt Punkt DE und,
Bundes äh BFV Punkt Bund Punkt DE, also am Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz äh geschrieben.
Äh von diesen vier E-Mails, die ich losgeschickt habe, äh wurde mir nur bei der einen vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz äh nicht zurückgemeldet, dass diese E-Mail-Adresse nicht existiert.
Beweis natürlich überhaupt nichts, ja? Aber ich frage mich ja nun wirklich, warum figurieren die eigentlich überhaupt ihre Mail Server so, dass man da so leicht rausfindet, was es da nicht gibt?
Das haben vielleicht noch nicht so viele Leute probiert, wobei ich das eigentlich erwarten würde, dass Leute mal gegen den Verfassungsschutz überall sauber getreten haben. Vielleicht traut man sich das aber auch einfach nicht.
Okay, also auch das beweist jetzt erst mal gar nichts so, aber ähm.
Du denn hast du denn mal den den Test gemacht einfach irgendein Kuddelmuddel-Adresse um zu gucken ob der überhaupt bei uns Nachrichten schick.
Ja klar. Nein, nein, also der schickt Bounce Nachrichten. Das habe ich gecheckt und ich habe das auch mit also ich habe sowohl Kuddelmundel,
auch so ungewöhnliche Namen, dass es sie vermutlich nicht beim Verfassungsschutz gibt. Also nicht deutsche Namen.
Und äh also der bounct wirklich nur bei Sachen, die es nicht gibt. Das habe ich auch,
mehrfach getestet ähm und deswegen dahingehend war das schon ein Hinweis. Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Michael Friedrich beim äh Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Michael Friedrich ist aber jetzt vielleicht in der Generation Sachsen um die 50 auch in aller Weltsnahme.
Deswegen vielleicht habe ich da auch jemanden ganz anderen erwischt. Da arbeiten immerhin ich glaube 4000 Leute oder so. Und.
Dann war es so halb drei glaube ich und da dachte ich so, das war jetzt so interessant beim BMI-Trepto. Ich rufe jetzt mal beim BMI Köln an.
Wohlgemerkt, das sind alles Telefonnummern, die du aus dieser Reibatenbank rausgeholt hast. Nirgendwo sonst stand die stand in auf keiner Webseite. Die waren nirgendswo verzeichnet, sondern es waren einfach nur die IP-Adressen-Kontakte.
Ähm die Nummer vom BMI Köln, die gab's noch an einer anderen Stelle. Ähm beim äh auf einer Webseite für Betriebssport, bei der sie auch als BMI Köln als äh Betriebssportstelle gelistet waren. Also es gibt ja so,
wenn Unternehmen irgendwie so Sportgruppen haben, dass die irgendwie Wettkämpfe gegeneinander machen und die Nummer vom BMI Köln war auch auf so einer Betriebssportgruppen-Webseite gelistet.
Aber sonst nirgends.
Betriebssport kommt okay.
Sport die machen.
Ähm warte, ich glaube, da steht da schon. Ich glaube Fußball und Volleyball oder so.
Hm, okay.
Also muss ich jetzt nochmal nachschauen aber ich glaube das war irgendwie Kombi so zwei Ballsportarten.
Und dann rufe ich so beim äh BMI Köln acht zum zwei äh oder halb drei schon an und natürlich denke ich, da geht niemand ran, weil ich wie gehabt den gibt es keine 24 Stunden Telefonnummern und ähm meldet sich sofort jemand,
auch hellwach wie so eine Telefonzentrale, Bundesministerium des Inneren in Köln, guten Abend. Äh wie kann ich ihnen helfen? Und dann äh,
Diesmal mache ich's richtig, sage ich guten Abend. Mein Name ist Wittmann. Bin ich hier denn richtig beim BMI Köln? Und dann sagt die Person, ja genau, sie sind ja beim BMI Köln.
Dann frage ich sie, sagen sie mal, wo in Köln sitzen sie eigentlich? Ich möchte ihnen was zuschicken.
Und dann sagt die Person ähm äh ja in Köln ähm ähm ich kann ihnen eine Postfachnummer geben ähm und danach das so ein bisschen ja kann ich ihnen was vorbeibringen?
Und ähm dann sagt die Person an irgendeinem Punkt, nee nee können sie nicht
ähm dann wollte ich dann habe ich so gefragt, aber sagen sie mal in Köln gibt es doch gar kein BMI. Wo wo habe ich denn da jetzt angerufen? Ist das jetzt hier doch der Verfassungsschutz?
Dann sagt die Person so, sehr sicher, nein, nein, sie sind hier beim Bundesministerium des Inneren in Köln und dann ging das so ein bisschen hin und her.
Und ähm dann wollte ich irgendwann noch mal wissen, ja und wo sitzt denn jetzt das Bundesministerium, das Innere in Köln? Sagen Sie mal, sitzen Sie dann an Ihrer Adresse vom Verfassungsschutz? Dann sagt die Person, nein, nein, dazu kann ich Ihnen keine Auskunft geben. Rufen Sie zur Dienstzeit wieder an und legt auf.
Also so richtig legt sofort auf und sagt nicht, ich beende jetzt das Gespräch oder so, einfach klack. Oh.
Und ähm diese Rufnummer, die ist auch weiterhin erreichbar rund um die Uhr,
und da Antworten verschiedene Menschen und äh wenn man das zu verschiedenen Tages- und Nachtzeiten ausprobiert, laufen die Gespräche ähnlich ab,
Sie können dir auch nicht sagen, in welchem Referat sie arbeiten, in welchem Liegenschaft oder Geschäftsbereich sie sind. Dazu können sie keine Auskunft geben. Sie können auch nichts, wenn man sich fragt, was sie machen, sagen sie, sie sind eine Telefonzentrale und sie verbinden Menschen von A nach B.
Sie können aber nicht sagen, mit wem man verbunden werden kann. Ähm und sie können dich auch nicht mit Leuten im BMI verbinden. Auch das habe ich ausprobiert.
Also das BMI in Köln, was es nicht gibt. Hat so eine Art Telefonzentrale, sagt man könnte sie würden dich gerne mit jemandem verbinden, aber darf nicht beim BMI sein.
Aber sie können ja auch nicht sagen, wo diese Personen, mit denen man sich vielleicht verbinden lassen könnte, sonst sein könnte.
Richtig.
Da dachte ich mir so, so eine 24 Stunden Telefon-Hotline, um Leute zu verbinden, ohne zu wissen, mit wem man sich denn da so verbinden kann,
ohne dass irgendwer in der Behörde auch die Sauersteine kennt, denn auch da habe ich wiederum gefragt da dachte ich mir so, so eine kaputt gesparte Behörde von McKinsey optimiert. Das wäre schon jemandem aufgefallen.
Ja.
Also vor ein paar Jahren hätte ich denen das vielleicht zugetraut, dass sie irgendwie gemerkt nicht gemerkt haben, dass sie noch das Telefonzentrale haben, von der niemand was weiß. Aber ich glaube, heute bis heute hätten die das schon gemerkt.
Tja.
Und eine dann war das recht ein bisschen naheliegend, dass das der Verfassungsschutz ist, weil ich meine, die haben ja auch in 20 Jahren ihre Mitarbeiterzahl verdoppelt und irgendwas müssen all diese Leute ja machen.
Und ähm ich hatte aber irgendwie keinen Beweis dafür, dass jetzt das BMI Köln,
auch wirklich Tarnbehörden des Verfassungsschutz sind, aber ich hatte so eine Menge Indizien und das sah alles sehr komisch aus.
Und äh alle Mitarbeiter haben das aber irgendwie weiterhin abgestritten. Ich habe da wirklich oft angerufen und ich habe da E-Mails hingeschrieben, IFG-Anfragen, Presseanfragen und das hat mich irgendwie aber alles nicht weitergebracht.
Wie lange äh diese ganze Ermittlungsgeschichte über was für einen Zeitraum reden wir da jetzt so insgesamt bis bis zu diesem Punkt.
Also also von ich habe angefangen zu recherchieren. Das war Anfang Dezember letzten Jahres.
Ähm an dem Punkt, dass ich das mit dem BMI trete und dem BMI Köln rausgefunden habe. Das war kurz bevor der erste Artikel erschienen ist, also sprich heute vor zwei Wochen so,
ähm und äh genau, aber erstaunlicherweise haben Behörden über IFG-Anfragen zu diesem Thema immer sehr schnell reagiert, weil sie nämlich immer gesagt haben, dass sie nichts dazu sagen können. Das war auch ein bisschen auffällig, weil oft wartet man ja auch so eine IFG-Anfrage einfach mal einen Monat,
und auf einmal geht das in zwei Tagen und ich war dann so ein bisschen frustriert und wusste nicht mehr, wie ich weitermachen soll,
und ich hatte wirklich
noch ganz viele andere Sachen probiert. Es gab irgendwie mal diese Hypothese, dass diese Adresse irgendwie was mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss zu tun hatte und dann habe ich Ströbele eine E-Mail geschrieben, ob ihm die Adresse was sagt
und dann kam aber immer nur ein Nein zurück und ich bin echt an ganz vielen Stellen immer so gegen so eine Wand gelaufen und nicht mehr weitergekommen und hatte irgendwie keine richtigen Beweise.
Und dann dachte ich so, ich habe ja diese Adresse in Köln, dieses Postfach. Wo landet denn diese Post eigentlich, wenn ich da was hinschicke?
In dieser wunderschönen Welt, wo man überall Bluetooth Slow Energy reinstecken kann, haben wir ja auch so was wie AirTex. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich so einen AirTech mal da diese Postfachadresse in Köln schicke.
Also AirTech von Apple, dieses kleine äh äh kleine äh Knopf sozusagen mit Batterie, die man irgendwo reintun kann und der funkt dann regelmäßig äh so Corona-Warnap-mäßig seine ID durch die Gegend und andere iPhones sehen das Ding und können dann äh
diese diesen Ort, wo man dieses empfangen hat, dann über Apple wieder an die Person weiterleiten, der diesen Attack gehört.
Ganz genau und äh ja, dann habe ich mir so einen Air-Tag gekauft, habe
das so verpackt, dass es nicht so ganz offensichtlich war, dass sein AirTech in der Verpackung ist, weil da soll ja niemand mal im Briefkasten auffallen. Also habe ich irgendwie so eine alte Reisezeitung genommen, habe ein Loch reingeschnitten und ein AirTech reingepackt,
Und na ja, habe das in einem Brief verschickt und das ging natürlich direkter Weg nach Köln
landete dann um acht Uhr dreißig morgens äh am Montag
danach äh ihren Brief zur Tierzentrum in Köln-Ehrenfeld. Und ich dachte noch so, ist der falsche Stadtteil, der Verfassungsschutz sitzt irgendwie ein bisschen weiter. Das passt nicht. Äh in Ehrenfeld da sitzt er nur Böhmermann. Ähm
und.
Steckt da wohl dahinter.
Hatte ich echt kurz Schiss. Und äh.
Wie regelmäßig waren denn die Updates? Also könntest du quasi das Paket die ganze Zeit verfolgen?
Es war super krass, genau. Hätte ich nicht erwartet. Also tatsächlich auch so von der Autobahn hatte ich irgendwie in zehn bis zwanzig Minuten Abstand Pings.
Also ich konnte wirklich sogar tracken wo der Fahrer zum Pinkeln Pause gemacht hat.
Mhm. Krass.
Also das hat mich so hat mich wirklich so ein bisschen überrascht. Also ich dachte so ja ich werde irgendwie Pinks bekommen, wenn das vielleicht in so einem so Sortierzentrum oder so liegt aber nee ich hatte tatsächlich wirklich Echtzeit-Pings auch von der Straße überall.
Kann natürlich sein, dass der Fahrer ein iPhone hatte und dann hast du das schon.
Äh genau, da ist halt so ein bisschen die Gefahr, dass der AirTech dann irgendwann zum Piepen anfängt oder das beim Fahrer aufm Display auftaucht, wobei als Postfahrer, was soll man da machen mit einem LKW von der Post.
Und na ja Montagmorgen um acht Uhr vierzig oder so tauchte er dann auf einmal,
am Gebäude des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz auf. Und das war der letzte Ping, den ich von ihm hatte.
Mhm. Und seitdem hat sich das auch nicht wieder gemeldet das Teil.
Nee, acht Uhr siebenunddreißig war der letzte Ping.
Hypothese ist tatsächlich, dass äh der Briefträger ein iPhone dabei hatte, ähm weil es wir haben tatsächlich quasi einen Ping O wirklich aus dem Gebäude ähm und Leute beim Verfassungsschutz müssen, soweit ich weiß, am Eingang ihr Telefon abgeben.
Und dann hat der Briefträger vielleicht irgendwie eine Kiste Post zum Verfassungsschutz bis reingebracht,
und ist dann mit seinem iPhone raus, weil dann hatte ich den Ping irgendwie erst so fünfzehn, zwanzig Minuten später angezeigt bekommen und dann hat er von da draußen von da drin das letzte Mal gesendet und ähm,
Aber damit war irgendwie klar, wurde in die Post ans BMI Köln hingeht.
Super Huck, ey, großartig, Mann.
War richtig schön getimed,
weil äh quasi eine Stunde, nachdem der AirTech angekommen ist, hat Thilo Jung in der Bundespressekonferenz gefragt, ob das denn äh ob das äh Bundesservice Telekommunikation eine Tanbehörde nach dem Bundesverfassungsschutzgesetz ist.
Und da wurde dann nur noch kein Kommentar gesagt.
Und das hatten wir so ein bisschen vorher abgestimmt und äh ja damit hatte man dann quasi so zwei Datenpunkte, die so ein bisschen eindeutig darauf hingewiesen haben, dass man da auch so ein,
Netzwerk von Tarnbehörden gestoßen ist.
Ja äh Applaus für für dein äh für dein Vorgehen. Also das da war ja wirklich eine ganze Menge äh Detektivarbeit äh äh dabei in bester Hacker-Mania.
Am Ende
auch nicht so überraschend, ne? Also ich meine okay, was haben wir jetzt gelernt so der Bundesverfassungsgeschütz hat halt irgendwelche Tatbehörden, die vielleicht unter Umständen Titelkommunikationsüberwachungen machen an so Standorten
in Lauf äh und Zigarettenpausenweite der anderen Standorte, wo man aber jetzt nicht so genau weiß, was die eigentlich machen und Glasfaseranschluss haben sie auch noch. So, okay, gut ja
das äh.
Jetzt alles nicht super unerwartet und ich meine im Nachhinein haben wir auch noch eine Menge mehr Hinweise gefunden oder haben Leute tatsächlich,
weitere Hinweise gefunden, wie dass das BMI Köln zum Beispiel Autos verkauft über die Zollauktionsplattform.
Und dass der Tarname BMI Köln schon im Jahr 1984, glaube ich, in Untersuchungsausschuss Dokumenten auftaucht,
Und da steht, dass dann mit der Verfassungsschutz gemeint ist. Also das sind so Sachen, die waren auch schon teilweise verfügbar.
Ja Mensch.
Aber witzig ist es trotzdem.
Ja natürlich super äh super unterhaltsam. Auf jeden Fall. Kleiner Krimi. Ähm,
Was ist denn äh so das das geplante Endergebnis deiner äh Strukturierungs äh Arbeit so beim Auslesen der Behördenstruktur? Was was was willst du denn da erreichen? Was was was soll denn da am Ende bei rauskommen?
Sei es nicht nur Hobby, ne.
Genau, also ich meine erstmal ist natürlich,
Dieses Stroh ist natürlich diese strukturierten Daten an sich haben irgendwie schon einen ziemlich krassen inherrenten Wert, wenn man darauf basierend aufbauend ja wieder eine ganze Menge neuen Krams
an Datenvisualisierung, ähm Lernmaterial und so weiter und so fort bauen können und natürlich ist erstmal das Ziel diese,
Datenstrukturierung tatsächlich auch wegen der Strukturierung zu machen. Ähm aber natürlich ist das Endziel, dass man,
eigentlich ganz viele dieser Storys, wie jetzt eine Bundesservice Telekommunikation, vielleicht dann nicht mehr in Bezug auf Geheimdienste, sondern in Bezug auf
Mittel verteilt wurden, äh wie Gesetze beraten wurden und so viel besser erzählen kann, weil man nämlich auf Basis von Daten dann diese Storys erzählen kann, die man irgendwie zusammengefügt hat und die man besser verständlich gemacht hat und.
Habe dann so das Gefühl, nachdem ich schon quasi bei der ersten Recherche über so was Spannendes gestolpert bin und man jetzt tatsächlich auch bei diesen Geheimdienstsachen immer wenn man irgendwo dran zieht, wieder was Neues findet,
ist da eigentlich noch ganz ganz ganz viel mehr Storys gibt und ähm dass es halt total wichtig ist, dass man damit zumindest mal anfängt an diesen einzelnen kleinen Maschen von so einem Wollpulli zu ziehen und zu schauen, was passiert.
Mhm aber es ist ja jetzt nicht dein primäres Ziel gewesen jetzt irgendwie die Tarnorganisation der Bundesregierung
aufzulisten und äh ich verstehe das jetzt auch so, dass äh die eigentliche Arbeit an dieser ganzen Strukturierungsgeschichte, wo er am Ende, ich weiß nicht genau, mit welchen Formaten du dann an die Welt gehen willst oder APs, aber du willst ja im Prinzip ein System bauen, wo man im Prinzip,
ähm offene Daten hat, so was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt eine App
baue, die halt in irgendeiner Form den politische die politische Arbeit unterstützen will, sagen wir mal, ich habe jetzt hier irgend so ein NGO und ich suche jetzt irgendwie die richtigen Ansprechpartner, um meinem mein Anliegen äh für einen bestimmten Bereich, ja.
Ich bin Wind äh Räder bauen, mit wem muss ich mich eigentlich unterhalten oder wenn ich irgendwie diese Gesetzesinitiative voranbringen möchte oder diese Reform, mit wem möchte ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich äh,
sprechen. So und dann einfach ein Werkzeug zu haben, wo er sagen kann, okay, wer könnte denn da zuständig sein und dann so, ja
hier diese Unterabteilung tralala mit den und den Ansprechpartnern und den äh Telefonnummern und IP-Adressen, dann kannst du dann äh vorstellig werden. Das sind vielleicht die richtigen Leute.
Genau und im besten Fall weiß ich dann auch schon, als es NGO, mit welchen Lobbyisten sich dieses Referat regelmäßig trifft, äh was die so zum Thema schreiben und so weiter und so fort. Also es geht wirklich einerseits natürlich darum, erstmal diese Struktur,
an sich als einen riesigen Grafen zu haben, aber dann auch superschnell darum halt einfach alle anderen Daten, die wir so haben als Zivilgesellschaft, an diesen Graf anzuheften.
Also wie zum Beispiel jetzt das neue Lobby-Register, was jetzt aufgebaut werden muss.
Genau, wie zum Beispiel das Lobbyregister oder alle Antworten, die es auf Frag den Staat gibt. Weil da hängt ja häufig eine E-Mail-Adresse von einem Referat dran und dann kann man diese Daten relativ einfach verknüpfen und dann hast du auf einmal eine schöne Verschlagwortung von allen Referaten.
Wer das Projekt ja vielleicht beifragt, den Staat auch ganz gut aufgehoben.
Also ich arbeite mit denen ja auch schon dahingehend zusammen und ich meine wir planen da auch schon glaube ich so ein bisschen so Sachen zusammen, aber genau, also so Stück für Stück äh muss man mal schauen, wo das dann am Ende genau landet,
weil ich glaube so ganz allein werde ich das halt nicht langfristig betreiben können, wenn man schon irgendwie über die erste krasse Story stolpert, wenn man nur,
die Liste von Behörden importiert dann wird das nämlich nie fertig, weil ich immer wieder eine andere spannende Story finde.
Ja, du hast äh offensichtlich ganz schön viele Hummeln äh im Arsch. Nebenbei äh laufen ja noch diese ganzen
Corona Sachen, diese Schnelltests äh Webseite, die ihr jetzt vor Kurzem noch aufgesetzt habt, um diese Schnelltests zu äh scannen. Da hast du doch, glaube ich, auch noch deine Finger mit drin, ne? Das ist ja so
Projekt von von der Gruppe zur Forschung. Vielleicht kannst du zur Zerforschung nochmal kurz was sagen.
Genau wir sind so ein Kollektiv von so knapp zehn Menschen, die halt irgendwie Spaß daran haben, Technik auseinanderzunehmen, Technik zu verstehen und halt genauer hinzuschauen, wie Sachen funktionieren.
Eigentlich war das mal so eine Gruppe von Menschen, die vor allem Hardware zerbastelt hat und irgendwie geschaut hat, wie so ein,
Fernseher aus China funktioniert und was da für ein Android draufläuft und wie man das hacken kann,
während Corona wurde daraus dann aber immer mehr, man schaut sich mal zum Beispiel äh Corona-Schnelltest-Buden an und ähm ja findet da Sicherheitslücken, die so fatal sind, dass man am Ende quasi
ohne irgendwas zu tun, die gesamte Datenbank dieser Corona-Schnelltestbuden in der Hand hat und ähm genau. Zur Forschung bin ich irgendwie letztes Jahr September gekommen und wir haben da,
keine Ahnung, Ende letzten Jahres, vor allem so eine größere Kampagne gemacht, wo wir uns irgendwie verschiedenste Bildungs-Apps angeschaut haben und einfach geschaut haben, wie kaputt die sind und dabei natürlich super viel gefunden haben. Gleichzeitig aber immer noch so dieses
ganze Coronathema.
Und jetzt zu Ende des Jahres, als wir einen Vortrag für den Kongress aufgezeichnet haben, war irgendwie so das Ding, dass wir uns äh für das ganze Team Schnelltests gekauft haben und äh wir haben uns Schnelltests gekauft, die richtig Scheiße waren, also die irgendwie so eine Erkennungsrate von,
16 Prozent oder so hatten. Und das hat uns so geärgert, dass es irgendwie keine einfache Möglichkeit gibt, zu checken, wie gut Schnelltests sind.
Und dann haben wir uns halt mal eben hingesetzt und haben so eine kleine Web-App gebaut, Schnelltest Punkt DE. Und ähm ja, das war dann so.
Fünfter bis fünfzehnter Januar oder so, haben wir uns halt hingesetzt und haben irgendwie manuell so eine Datenbank vom äh Paul-Ehrlich-Institut, die diese Schnelltests äh tatsächlich testen, importiert und haben die mit so Ehren, also so so Strichcodes, die auf den Schnelltests drauf sind verknüpft.
Und haben das als App gestartet und wir haben natürlich nicht damit gerechnet, dass das so viele Leute so cool finden, aber
über die letzte Woche quasi jeden Tag ein Interview zu diesem Thema gegeben und das läuft
überall in den in den Medien rauf und runter und äh das unterschätzt man dann immer so ein bisschen ganz schnell, wie groß und wie anstrengend so ein Thema werden kann und ist natürlich trotzdem total cool, das gemacht zu haben.
Ja auch so ist es äh ich meine es gab ja auch schon solche Webseiten bloß wir sind einfach nicht auf diese einfache Idee gekommen das über den EAN äh verknüpfen. Ähm wobei es gilt ja auch so Schnelltests, die es von so Praxisdiensten versendet werden und so. Da sind dann gar keine Eher eins drauf, ne.
Es gibt diese Schnelltests, die halt nur in Apotheken verkauft werden. Die haben dann häufig eine PZN-Nummer, also eine Pharma-Zentralregisternummer. Die erfassen wir mittlerweile auch und dann gibt es tatsächlich auch einzelne Tests,
gar keinen Barcode haben, gerade wenn die halt so ja im professionellen Umfeld eingesetzt werden und aber es sind nicht so viele, aber
wussten wir vorher auch nicht. Also allgemein war sind wir natürlich nicht die perfekten Leute, um so ein Projekt umzusetzen, weil ich meine, wir haben alle nicht so super viel Erfahrung mit Schnelltests und wenn dann mehr so mit Schnelltestszentren, wenn wir sehen, dass der ein Software kaputt ist.
Aber irgendwie hat das ja niemand so zugänglich vorher gebaut,
und äh wäre natürlich eigentlich so der Job der Verwaltung mal wieder gewesen und dann haben wir uns halt doch hingesetzt und das gemacht, weil.
Ja da sind wir wieder im Prinzip am Anfang unseres äh Gesprächs ne und der äh des des des bedauernswürdigen Zustands ähm unserer Behörden in puncto Digitalisierung. Was ist denn so dein,
Blick da drauf. Also ich meine, wie reformfähig äh ist denn dieser Apparat? Äh hängen die jetzt einfach äh äh nur ein paar Jahre zurück und das das das wird sich jetzt schon irgendwie einruckeln oder hast du so den Eindruck, dass das irgendwie so ein systemisches generelles,
oder vielleicht auch kulturelles Problem ist, was was meinst du, woran hakt es denn da? Wir haben uns die Frage hier auch schon öfter mal gestellt, mich,
mal deine Perspektive äh interessieren.
Also grundsätzlich ist erstmal alles kaputt.
Ähm also das sehen wir ja auch alle irgendwie so. Und äh ich finde man kann das halt so auf so zwei Kernpunkte runterbrechen und das eine ist natürlich die fehlenden Kompetenzen.
Also sehen wir ja, dass es irgendwie in der Verwaltung zum Thema Digitalisierung irgendwie quasi keine Inhousekompetenzen gibt,
sondern wir haben da viel Generalistinnen, ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Idee von der Verwaltung lange gewesen, dass man irgendwie viele Verwaltungswissenschaftlerinnen und viele Juristinnen hat, aber nicht so viele Leute, die sich irgendwie tatsächlich mit Digitalisierung auskennen.
Und der andere Punkt ist, dass wir Strukturen haben, die dazu führen, dass ja einige wenige.
Entscheidungen treffen, auch Entscheidungen treffen, die sie vielleicht nicht vollständig verstehen.
Und das bedeutet natürlich dann, dass man irgendwie Leute hat, die nicht so viel Ahnung haben, die sich irgendwie was ausdenken und dann hast du Leute, die nicht so viel Ahnung haben, die darüber entscheiden.
Ähm und wir müssten diese beiden großen Punkte angehen, nämlich einmal.
Innenbehörden ganz viel Know-How aufbauen, also sprich Leute, die tatsächlich wissen, wie man die Digitalisierung funktioniert und damit meine ich jetzt,
nicht so Leute, die irgendwie so ein bisschen äh Design Thinking spielen können in der Verwaltung, sondern tatsächlich Leute, die Sachen auch umsetzen können, die Produkte sein können und so weiter und so fort. Also alle Kompetenzen, die man in so einer digitalen Welt halt braucht,
in die Verwaltung reinzuholen,
und dann den Leuten aber auch den Freiraum zu geben, damit die tatsächlich das machen können, was sinnvoll ist, denn das sind ja häufig Menschen,
die vorher in dem Umfeld gearbeitet haben, wo man ihnen relativ viel Eigenverantwortung gegeben hat und wo man irgendwie Leuten zutraut, dass sie irgendwie selber wissen, was richtig ist und was sinnvoll ist zu bauen und wo man nicht auf diese klassische Verwaltungsstruktur setzt.
Wo man irgendwie Leute hat, die zwar irgendwas machen, aber dann geht das über so eine ganz lange Leiter bis zu der Person, die das entscheidet,
Und dann entscheidet die das ohne superviel Fachkompetenz zu haben. Ich glaube, wenn man diese beiden sich an diesen beiden Schrauben dreht,
Könnte man zu einem Punkt kommen, das staatliche Digitalisierung, gerade auf Bundesebene funktionieren könnte. Anders wird schwierig.
Na ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt einen Brief bekommen würdest, meine dich haben sie ja erstmal rausgeschmissen, als du dich dann entsprechend äh verhalten hast, aber vielleicht liegt es auch da dran, dass du immer so frech bist. Ähm aber
Ich meine, ist ja auch klar, dass es natürlich jetzt auch nicht so ein wie soll ich sagen,
attraktives Umfeld erstmal, ne? Also ich meine zu wissen, dass es genau da äh alles so ein bisschen ausm Mund riecht und genau da soll man dann sozusagen reingehen und
äh alles durchrevolutionieren, wenn man dann vielleicht selber aber auch wiederum so wenig Berührungspunkte mit so Verwaltungen hat und da nicht so eine,
ja, nicht so seinen King irgendwie äh von vornherein hat. Ähm
natürlich dann schon mal sehr schwierig sowas äh attraktiv zu machen. Das Zweite ist sicherlich für die Leute, die wirklich jetzt richtig viel Produktkompetenz haben und irgendwie
so dieses Wissen haben mit so ah okay, wir brauchen jetzt mal eine Webseite, zack
Bums. Machen wir jetzt mal in zwei Stunden. Ähm ja auch so so breit nicht gesät und die Leute haben dann vielleicht eben auch einfach keinen Bock oder sehen da einfach auch zu wenig Verdienstmöglichkeiten oder zu wenig Freiheiten oder eine Kombination aus allem um da auch,
hinzu wollen und hingelockt werden zu können.
Absolut und ich meine ich glaube der Kernpunkt dabei ist halt häufig die Freiheit, die den Leuten fehlt. Also dass sie halt nicht irgendwie das machen können, was sinnvoll ist,
sondern halt in bestehende anstrengende Strukturen reinkommen und sich dann erstmal etablieren müssen und äh das halt super frustrierend ist, wie halt auch in so konservativen Unternehmen, die das ja häufig auch nicht.
Aber ich meine das hier was, das kann man irgendwie angehen und was dieses Verdienstthema angeht, ist das halt auch vor allem so ein Ding von
Verwaltung muss das halt wollen. Also die TVÖD, also Tarifvertrag, öffentliche Dienst, bietet super viel Spielraum, wie du jemanden eingrupierst und wie du jemanden bezahlst.
Du magst da jetzt nicht auf die kommen und du magst da jetzt auch nicht auf die Valley auf die Gehälter die irgendwie Leute ausm äh Companys ausm Valley in Berlin bezahlen kommen aber du kommst schon auf gute Industrie übliche Gehälter, wenn du Leute richtig eingruppieren möchtest.
Und das sieht man irgendwie beim BM BND und beim Verfassungsschutz, wenn die irgendwie IT-Leute suchen, dann kriegen die das mit der Eingruppierung hin,
Ähm das ist ganz witzig. Äh und dass das irgendwie bei vielen anderen Behörden nicht klappt, ähm,
Ja, also das ist halt vor allem so dem Wille der Personalabteilung geschuldet, dass die halt irgendwie sehen müssen, wenn ich einen guten Produktdesigner einstelle, dann sollte ich ihn vielleicht so eingruppieren, wie auch einen Juristen.
Und dann klappt das auch, aber das tun sie halt in der Regel nicht.
Also mit anderen Worten, du du du sagst das eigentlich in den Ministerien äh so so so deutlich das jetzt mal noch nicht genug,
erkannt wurde, dass das sozusagen ein generelles Problem ist, was man wirklich mal äh damit lösen muss, äh wirklich hoch,
qualifiziertes Personal zu installieren, weil bisher immer so Digitalisierung ist so die das hässliche Kind irgendwie was in der Ecke steht und mit dem Karim.
Genau, Digitalisierung in dem Ministerium bedeutet heute häufig, dass man halt irgendeinem Referatsleiter, der vorher
irgendeine Bildungsinitiative gemanagt hat, die nichts mit Digitalisierung zu tun hatte, aber der hat sich irgendwie bisher gut angestellt hat, sagt, hey, du bekommst jetzt dieses 100 Millionen Euro Digitalisierungsprojekt,
Verwalte das mal. Also ein Mensch, der keine Ahnung hat, was er da eigentlich tut. Macht auf einmal Digitalisierung.
Natürlich klappt das nicht und was macht diese Person dann? Hat ja keine Fachkompetenzen um sich rum, holt sich die nächstbeste Beratungsbude rein und ähm,
Rätseln wieder zur nächsten Beratungsbude und so weiter und so fort. Und dabei wird natürlich keinerlei Kompetenz in Haus aufgebaut durch so Riesenprojekte, sondern was dann halt immer nur passiert ist, dass man halt irgendwie Geld nach draußen verbrennt, ein Projekt mit,
absurden Laufzeiten, absurden Kosten hat, dass am Ende dann halt häufig nicht wirklich jemandem hilft, weil es wurde ja einfach irgendwann mal politisch entschieden, das muss gebaut werden und jemand für den Digitalisierung halt einfach das nächste Projekt war,
das dann irgendwie umgesetzt und der weiß, wegen der Rotation in zwei Jahren macht er wieder eh wieder was anderes,
Alles gut? Äh zieht er durch. Ähm aber so funktioniert das halt nicht sinnvoll und dieses Ding von ja man baut wirklich inhouse Kompetenzen auf, ist halt bisher an den wenigsten Stellen angekommen.
Linus, hast du noch dem Hinweis hinzuzufügen? Hast du vielleicht Interesse an so einem Job?
Ich habe kein Interesse an so einem Job und äh aber ich habe mal, ich war vor kurzem bei so einer Veranstaltung und äh das hören die total ungerne, wenn man sagt, so wie ihr die Leute bezahlt, könnte ja keine ordentlichen Leute,
Lässt dann eine Person aus dem Publikum aufgestanden und die war total böse auf mich. Ähm und ich habe ich habe erst nachher so
hoffen nach Hause, Weg gemerkt. Ach so, ja wahrscheinlich. Ich habe mir ja auch einen Grund gegeben,
böse auf mich zu sein, ja? Und dann wird auch gerne betont, dass ja mitunter ja die Beamtenlaufbahn,
äh hohe soziale Sicherheit bietet und das alles gar nicht so ein schlechtes Angebot wäre. Ähm aber ja, natürlich hast du äh Recht und äh da.
Das mag vereinzelt natürlich kompetente Leute geben, aber die gehen dann eben eventuell auch mal wieder, ne?
Äh sogenannten Welly-Gehälter, ja, die sind ja auch also hm wenn man sich mal überlegt
so kompliziert ist IT ja dann auch nicht. Ja also finde ich zumindest äh ist tatsächlich auch immer erschreckend simpel dann doch ja ähm dass ich ähm etwas überrascht bin.
Ja wie hohe Gehälter dann teilweise eben für ja in meinen Augen dann trivial Aufgaben,
gezahlt werden ne? Also es ist ich würde jetzt sagen mal die in der Wirtschaft gezahlten,
IT-Gehälter, die sind primär Ausdruck eines Mangels, ja, also eines Marktmangels, dass es wenig Leute gibt, die diese ähm,
Kompetenzen haben, ja?
Gleichzeitig liegt das wenige Leute, diese Kompetenzen haben, aber nicht unbedingt daran, dass die jetzt so unglaublich kompliziert wären, dass nur ein paar wenige Genies diese Kompetenzen bekommen können, sondern es liegt und da bin ich ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen wieder näher an dem Limit, womit du dich auch gerne befasst, eben diesen Bildungsbereich. Das
die beim beigebracht wird, das heißt äh oder ne in der Schule irgendwie die Existenz des Internets so lange wie möglich verheimlicht wird. Ähm das heißt
die Menschen, die jetzt irgendwie in Frage kommen in solche Positionen äh zu gelangen, die diese Kompetenzen haben. Die haben die irgendwo.
Anders her. Ja, also die haben die nicht in der normalen Schulausbildung in in nennenswertem Ausmaß mitbekommen und deswegen sind sie auch selten. Wäre jetzt so meine meine Einschätzung. Würdest du das auch so sehen oder.
Hältst du dich für genial.
Nee, absolut nicht. Ich meine, ich habe mich einfach nur früh angefangen mit diesen Themen zu beschäftigen und ich
ich kann das alles auch nicht so unfassbar gut. Es ist einfach nur ja, es gibt nicht genug Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen und selbst was ich häufig sehe ist, selbst wenn die Verwaltung es irgendwo mal schafft,
sinnvoll Weiterbildung zu machen, hast du dann häufig dieses Ding, dass die Leute dann erkennen, dass sie jetzt anderswo angenehmere Arbeitsbedingungen bekommen können und anderswo vielleicht,
machen können. Sprich selbst wenn die Verwaltung das mal schafft sinnvoll Bildungsangebote zu machen, was tatsächlich schon passiert ist gehen diese Leute dann häufig nach diesen Weiterbildungen.
So, ich bin frei! Ich ich kann etwas einen Computer.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht.
Kann meinen alten Job wegautomati.
Es ist sicherlich nicht einfach jetzt so. Also ich meine äh ich will gar nicht hier so rausgehen und sagen so ja selber Schuld, ihr müsst ja nur hier irgendwie da mal äh ein bisschen am Personalschlüssel drehen und dann läuft das schon von alleine. Das das ist es natürlich nicht, sondern das ist natürlich eine.
Kurzfristig schon langfristig müsste man halt, ne, muss die muss muss muss wenn du sagst, wenn du erkennst, dass du einen Mangel an einer bestimmten Kompetenz
nicht nur in der Verwaltung, sondern in der gesamten Gesellschaft hast, dann,
ne, dann kannst du halt in Deutschland sagen, ja okay, jetzt bezahlen wir mehr oder in China gehen sie halt hin und sagen, wo haben wir Platz? Ah, da hinten ist Platz, bau da mal eine Universität hin.
Weißt du? Und äh sorg mal bitte dafür, dass hier in vier Jahren ähm äh
pro Jahr äh oder pro Semester oder jedem zweiten Semester 4000 Informatik-Master rauspurzeln. Die können wir gerade gebrauchen. Ne also das diese,
also der Missstand ist ja offensichtlich, der wird von allen die ganze Zeit beklagt, aber du siehst nicht, dass irgendwo mal Schritte geleitet äh eingeleitet werden, dass sich das in zwei Jahrzehnten wenigstens mal ändern könnte in Deutschland.
Ja absolut und auch dieses Ding von, dass ähm die Verwaltung wahrnimmt, dass man ganz viele Rollen bei ihnen in der Zukunft nicht mehr brauchen wird, weil man halt viele Sachbearbeiterinnen in dem, was sie Tag für Tag tun.
Wunderbar automatisieren kann. Das will natürlich nicht so viele Leute hören so,
aber am Ende des Tages, wenn man sich halt so Aufgaben gerade auf Kommunalebene anschaut, dann äh wenn man das mal ernsthaft durchziehen würde,
werde halt ein sehr hoher Automatisierungsgrad notwendig und das ist deswegen völlig klar ist, dass man irgendwie anfangen muss sich all diese Digitalkompetenzen die irgendwie die Basisinfrastruktur unseres Status bilden sollten
mal reinzuholen in die Behörden, statt zu sagen, ja ja Digitalisierung wichtig, machen wir jetzt auch was,
rufen wir mal gerade die kleine Agentur von nebenan an. Dann bastelt die uns da was und dann haben wir Digitalisierung auf unserer Liste abgehackt. Dann sind wir digital und machen auch immer dasselbe.
Ähm das diese komplette Idee von Digitalisierung ist gesellschaftlicher Wandel fehlt halt.
Genau und darauf wollte ich ein bisschen hinaus. Das ist,
letztlich natürlich auch die Schuld der Gesellschaft, ne, weil äh dieser Druck auf die Politik in dem Sinne ja auch nicht groß war. Sondern dieses ganze ach ja digital,
Habe doch mein Fax-Gerät und so, das ist auch schon digital genug. Das ist ja jetzt nicht nicht so, dass dass dieser Gedanke
nur da existiert, wo eine Behörde drumherum gebaut ist, sondern das das hast du ja überall. Das hattest du lange Zeit auch in den in den Unternehmen, das hast du in Schulen, das hast du einfach generell,
in uns es uns jetzt mal,
die diese Gesamtgesellschaft. Ich glaube, das ändert sich gerade. Das kriege ich gerade eine Beschleunigung.
Hat sicherlich noch nicht den Speed und die Qualität, die wir gerne sehen würden, aber ähm es fängt langsam an zu zu klingeln, so und ähm
bin zuversichtlich, dass dass ich da in den nächsten Jahren äh etwas in Bewegung setze. Ob wir damit glücklich sein werden oder ob das ausreichend ist,
habe ich noch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Ähm ich bin bin sehr bereit, mich äh überraschen zu lassen, auch wenn ich meinen grundpessimistischen Ausblick äh an der Stelle derzeit noch nicht bereit bin abzugeben.
Hach ja seufz.
Wollen wir mal über ein äh ein schönes deutsches Digitalisierungsprojekt an dieser Stelle sprechen, um mal den den Rest unserer Meldungen.
Zu arbeiten. Mach mal. Da hatten wir doch noch was.
Impfzertifikate, ja?
Viele unserer Hörerinnen erinnern sich an die von vielen Leuten, glaube ich, inzwischen als legendär eingestufte hm Folge über die fünf Blockchains, äh mit denen die Impfzertifikate in Deutschland äh versenkt werden sollten.
Und genau diese Impfzertifikate, da gibt's jetzt eine wunderschöne Statistik zu, die ihr auch alle rätseln lässt. Und zwar wurden
24,7 Millionen digitale Impfzertifikate ausgestellt,
Ähm in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland wurden aber zum gleichen Zeitpunkt nur ein
62,1 Millionen Dosen für Erstzeit und Dritimpfung, Dritimpfung gespritzt. Also wurden 42,6 Millionen Impfzertifikate zu viel aufgestellt.
So jetzt ähm fragt man, also auf Anhieb denkt man so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, ne? Ähm sind das jetzt alles gefälschte?
Oder wo kommen die her.
Aber jetzt von einzelnen Zertifikaten und nicht für Personen, ne.
Wir reden von einzelnen Impfdosen und von einzelnen Impfzertifikaten.
Also eine Person kann ja bis zu drei Impfzertifikate auf sich vereinen und wobei für den größeren Teil der Leute das,
oder für einen großen Teil der Leute das erste Impfzertifikat quasi nicht notwendig war. Weil es das Impfzertifikat noch nicht gab und sie quasi mit dem mit der zweiten Impfung dann einfach ein zwei von zwei Zertifikat bekommen haben und das war dann auch gut,
ähm und jetzt gibt es also in der in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ungefähr 162 Millionen Dosen, die geimpft wurden,
24 Millionen digitale Zertifikate. Und jetzt fragt man sich warum, wo kommt det her? Warum gibt es so viele.
Und ähm als ich diesen Artikel getwittert habe, gab es relativ viele ähm Antworten. Die das jetzt mal so ein bisschen erklären. Also wie gesagt, die ersten Leute, die geimpft wurden,
Die konnten ja zum Beispiel noch gar nicht so was bekommen. Dann gab es aber auch Leute, die,
dann mit ihrem also die quasi nachher noch so ein Impfzertifikat vom Impfzentrum zugeschickt bekommen haben. Vielleicht aber in der Zwischenzeit schon einmal in der Apotheke waren, um sich einen,
schon mal eins auszustellen,
Dann gab es fehlerhafte Ausstellungen. Name falsch geschrieben, Geburtsdatum falsch. Äh Entschuldigung, ich heiße Müller, nicht Meier, ne? Also oh vertan.
Äh genau, erneute Ausstellung bei Verlust, ja? Niemand hindert dich daran, dir so viele digitale Impfzertifikate zu holen äh wie du möchtest.
Ja? Gehst du einfach hin, lässt dir ein Neues ausstellen, dann behindert dich ja niemand dran, jetzt in eine Apotheke zu gehen und.
Auch davon hatten wir äh haben wir glaube ich in den Kommentaren und auch in den äh also unter meinem Tweet oder und auch glaube ich in den Kommentaren zur letzten Sendung
ausländische Personen. Die haben dann halt die, weißt du, die wurden von mir aus was weiß ich, in Polen geimpft oder so und äh oder Polen ist jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil EU, aber was weiß ich, irgendwo geimpft.
Und lassen sich dann hier ein Zertifikat ausstellen, damit das eben in Deutschland oder in der EU problemlos ähm anerkannt wird. Das sind so äh,
Gründe dafür, dass das vielleicht zu viele ausgestellt wurden. Mir persönlich würde noch einer einfallen. Ja
Da bin ich aber jetzt ein bisschen äh ich will jetzt nicht immer den Apothekern
äh unterstellen, dass sie vielleicht in der Freizeit mal einfach ein paar Impfzertifikate ausgestellt haben, weil die ja eine ganze Reihe,
also eine ganze Menge Kohle dafür bekommen haben, ne. Also die haben ja ich glaube so eine Ärztin hat drei Euro bekommen und eine Apotheke. Was war denn das? 27 oder sowas?
Zumindest haben die Apotheken ja anfangs dir die die wenn du da hingegangen bist haben sie bei dir ja auch gemacht Tim. Haben die dir ja nochmal das eins von zwei Zertifikat.
Ja auch haben.
Hat die Apotheke sich für bedankt? Haben Sie einfach das doppelte Geld bekommen, weil Sie ja 22 Zertifikate ausgestellt haben.
Totaler Unsinn, ne? Also was zeigt das.
Unsinn. Ich wusste zu dem Zeitpunkt ja gar nicht, dass ich das äh nicht brauche.
Die Apotheke wusste.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, aber kann auch sein.
Ich denke aber schon mit großer Sicherheit, dass die das wussten. Na ja, egal. Ähm entscheidend ist hier wir sehen
letztendlich, das wird wahrscheinlich schon seine Richtigkeit haben in diesen 42,6 Millionen sind natürlich auch,
Diejenigen, die mit gefälschten gelben Impfpässen in der Apotheke gegangen sind und sich daraus eine
äh ein ein Upgrade auf ein digitales geholt haben. Ne, diese Fälle haben wir hier besprochen. Nur das werden nicht 2und4 Millionen sein. Ich würde mal schätzen, also das,
Vielleicht eine eine einstellige, niedrige Millionenzahl. Wäre jetzt so mein Gefühl, vielleicht auch,
wird die dann vielleicht ist die oder sogar hoch einstellig aber mehr nicht. Aber man sieht hier einfach ein äh,
ja vielleicht auch nicht zu Ende gedacht das System, weil was wir bemängelt haben ist, dass es keine Revocation gibt.
Und irgendjemand, der jemand an, weißt du, wenn wenn da ein Unicode Fehler ist oder was weiß ich, falscher Name, falsches Geburtsdatum eingetippt oder so. Das sind alles gültige Impfzertifikate, die halt in diesen Counter mit eingeflossen sind. Ähm,
dass du allerdings, weißt du, wenn du hundertsechzig ausstellst, noch mal fünfundzwanzig,
Prozent mehr machst, weil du Fehler hast, äh ist natürlich auch ein bisschen bisschen erstaunlich. Aber eigentlich würde ich sagen, zeigt das nur, dass seit Revocation doch durchaus eine.
Ja vielleicht eine eine ein sinnvolles Feature gewesen wäre, was das äh BMG hätte beauftragen können.
Fallen dir sonst noch Gründe ein, dass äh Impfzertifikat also 40 Millionen ist schon echt eine Menge, ne.
Ist schon eine Menge also ich könnte das jetzt nicht so qualifizieren oder will das jetzt nicht so quantifizieren aber ist halt auf jeden Fall auch klar dass wenn man irgendwie äh
so eine hm Identifikationsinfrastruktur oder Zertifizierungsinfrastruktur ausrollt, man sich eben auch schon Gedanken darüber machen muss, wie man so was
beobachten die Backen äh und im Zweifelsfall äh bei Fehlern auch wieder eingefangen äh einfangen kann und das ist halt hier aus Zeitgründen einfach so nicht gemacht worden, ne? Sondern man hat halt gesagt so ja so passt schon irgendwie und dann äh
gehen wir mal los, weil muss ja jetzt ganz schnell fertig sein. Wir hatten am Anfang so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, wie lange das wohl dauert, so was irgendwie aufzubauen. Dann ging das alles sehr viel schneller, als wir gesagt haben.
Wissen wir aber auch warum, ne?
Ja ähm.
Deine Meinung, Lillit.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hatte dieses System auch eine richtig schlechte UX und na ja, also ich hatte mal jemandem mit dem Ausstellen über die Schulter geschaut,
und da gibt also da hat irgendwie der Schritt gefehlt von, bitte schau hier nochmal an, ob du die Namen der Person richtig eingetippt hast und so und ich kann mir auch einfach vorstellen, dass das ganz häufig passiert ist, dass Leute das einfach doppelt machen mussten und ähm.
Also ja äh das das wirkte alles nicht so, als hätte sich da jemand hingesetzt und sich so richtig viel Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie verhindere ich Fehler beim Ausstellen und natürlich wäre es sinnvoll gewesen, ne Pervocation-Infrastruktur zu haben. Ich meine, das ist der größte Witz, dass man Zertifikate nicht zu.
Und ich meine allein so eine Information wie,
ich hab hier ein Fehler gemacht, ich möchte gerne dieses Zertifikat nochmal ausstellen. Das ist ja eine Information, die man nun im Rahmen dieses Ausstellprozesses einfach auch mal mitführen könnte. So und.
Ja gut, dann machst du einfach einmal kurz einen neuen NFT. Ja, den musst du.
Ja, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Also man diese Information,
ja wie oft wurde etwas mehrfach ausgestellt und äh sozusagen etwas, was drei Minuten alt ist, äh sofort schon wieder gelöscht. Ähm die hätte man ja mit.
Erfassen können und dann hätte man diese Information, hätte man diese Zahl so und vielleicht wären dann schon mal ein großer, zweistelliger äh Millionenzahl Betrag da weggegangen von dieser äh Rechnung hier. Aber ist halt nicht so.
Gleichzeitig muss man natürlich sagen, ich meine ein Impfzertifikat ist äh für eine Person immer nur dann gültig, wenn die Person auch nachweisen kann, dass sie sie selbst ist. Und insofern ist das
quasi auch egal, ne. Also also man ne, man könnte argumentieren, solange das jetzt also wenn du jetzt fünf Mal,
Lilit Wittmann falsch schreibst. Na gut, dann äh gibt's eben viermal vier Nichten,
Sinf nicht wirklich gültige Zertifikate. Ja und jede jede Person, die sich damit ausweisen möchte, müsste eben auch nochmal nachweisen, dass sie Little Widmann ist.
Tschau. Oder Impfregister und dann einfach mitm mitm mitm schön mitm äh Personalausweis äh identifizieren und sich.
Das muss man natürlich auch jetzt dazu sagen. Das ist eben natürlich auch ein Phänomen von man hat kein Impfregister.
So, das ist ja eigentlich auch erst mal positiv. Also so dramatisch, so schlimm ist es nicht, aber es äh es ist ein ein Testament für die für die Qualität.
Dieses Prozesses, ne, wenn da so viele Fehler offenbar bei auftreten,
Aber irgendjemand kommentierte auch, wenn er sein wenn er ohne Handy ausm Haus geht, dann äh würde er gerne mal in eine Apotheke vorbeigehen und sich ein neues geben lassen.
Wo ich mir so denke äh also,
erstens gehe ich sowieso nie ohne Handy ausm Haus und zweitens, wenn ich ohne Handy aus dem Haus gehe, da habe ich garantiert nicht meinen gelben Impfpass dabei, aber okay äh äh unterschiedliche, ne? Jede Jeck ist anders. Ähm,
komm wir kommen zu einer zunächst einmal positiven Nachricht Julian Assange darf.
In in eine Berufung gehen zu seinem äh zu seiner zu der Gerichtsentscheidung, dass er äh äh liefert werden soll, ja? Also,
Es wird jetzt vor den vor das höchste britische Gericht gehen, den den Supreme Court. Ob Julian Assange ähm ausgeliefert wird an die USA,
oder nicht. Ja.
Da wollen wir mal hoffen, dass vielleicht das höchste Gericht in in UK noch irgendwie halbwegs alle äh äh Tassen im Schrank hat. Denn was was drohen dem 173 Jahre Haft oder so ähm.
Nehme auch an, er hat schon angekündigt, dass er das tun wird.
Na ja, das haben sie ja überhaupt erst mal erstritten, dass sie das dürfen, ja. Ähm.
Dann gibt's ein interessantes äh Urteil des äh BGH. Ähm Facebook hatte ja von Beginn an.
Eine Klarnamenpflicht und jetzt haben hier äh mehrere Personen.
Gegen Facebook geklagt, dass sie ihre Facebook-Profile unter Pseudonym betreiben dürfen.
Ähm,
Allerdings müssen sie dem Unternehmen ihre wirklichen Namen angeben, aber sie dürfen quasi also sie dürfen quasi sagen was weiß ich, ich bin Mickey Mouse äh oder mein Profil heißt Mickey Mouse und hier ist mein Ausweis, wer ich wirklich bin.
Ja? Ähm und das gilt aber nur für Profile vor zwanzig18.
Ähm weil sich dann irgendwie die Gesetzeslage geändert hat oder die rechtliche Lage und Facebook jetzt dann quasi für Profile danach im Prinzip eine Ausweis und eine Klarnamenpflicht erzwingen kann, aber äh davor eben nicht.
Auch irgendwie absurd, weil die das eine pseudonyme Nutzung möglich sein muss war
allen bekannt, dass das einfach das Gesetz ist und dass Facebook nicht einfach diese Klarnamenpflicht erzwingen kann, haben sie aber eben über,
glaube dann, was sind das? Zehn Jahre oder so. Problemlos gemacht und du musst dann irgendwie zwanzig, zweiundzwanzig vom BGH äh das erstreiten, dass es bis zwanzig achtzehn geltendes Recht war, äh dass du dass du nicht ähm
unter Facebook äh gezwungen werden kannst, das Profil dort unter deinem richtigen Namen zu führen. Das ist wirklich.
Und wodurch ist es jetzt nicht mehr möglich? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ähm ich muss tatsächlich sagen, dass ich diesen genauen Umstand, warum sie's ab zwanzig achtzehn äh warum es nur bis zwanzig achtzehn geht, auch noch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden habe. Ähm,
wahrscheinlich äh finde ich das aber jetzt relativ schnell. Also zwei Personen haben geklagt, weil.
Facebook ihre Nutzerkonten deaktiviert hatte. Ja und,
Facebook hat die deaktiviert wegen Verstoß gegen die AGB, weil sie nicht im richtigen Namen waren, ja? Und jetzt haben die halt dann die Facebook verklagt und die Accounts müssen jetzt wiederhergestellt werden. Ja? Und das gilt ein,
also diese das Facebook.
Deinen Account nicht löschen darf, gilt nur vor dem Inkrafttreten des neuen europäischen Datenschutzrechts im Mai 20018.
Denn davor war im deutschen Tele Mediengesetz, äh die Pflicht, dass die Nutzung äh und ihre Bezahlung anonym oder unter pseudonym möglich sein muss.
Und offenbar es mit dem neuen Datenschutzrecht 20018 dieser Aspekt nicht äh vollumfänglich.
Ähm da gewesen.
Berichtete nicht.
Pflicht damit also dass das damit es mir auch nicht ganz klar. Ich vermute dass das jetzt eher etwas ist oder war mir nicht in dieser Form präsent, ja.
Na ja, Gelegenheit für äh euch in den Kommentaren uns mal wieder äh.
Also ergänzt es in der EU-Datenschutzverordnung ist einfach nicht geregelt ob man ein Recht auf äh Pseudonym hat.
Hm, okay.
Und deswegen bleibt für alle nach dem Mai 20018 erstellten Accounts die lagerechtlich ungeklärt.
Ja? Also dieses Urteil gilt bis 20018 Tele-Medien-Gesetz, das heißt im Prinzip müsste man jetzt nochmal hingehen und das auch nochmal für nach zwanzigzehnacht klären lassen. Allerdings hatten die Leute offenbar ihre Accounts vor 201acht erstellt. Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Was man da äh hinkriegt. Aber wie gesagt, die mussten äh müssen Facebook trotzdem gegenüber sagen. Äh sagen wir sie sind.
Na gut, da kann man ja dann auch noch mal so einen alten Account kann man ja vielleicht ganz gut monetarisieren. So, auf eBay packen und so. Hier braucht noch jemand ein Pseudonym Facebook-Account. Wenig Follower, aber pseudony.
Ja ich bin mir allerdings nicht sicher, ob Facebook nicht dagegen der AGB hat und die dann auch wirksam ist.
Neuer Pseudonym, man weiß ja nicht, wer dahinter.
Der äh äh reden wieder die die Nichtanwälte von.
Ja ja, ist ja schon gut. Ich mache ja nur Witze. Er will doch nur spielen.
Dann gab es einen sehr spannenden Fall, den wir vor einiger Zeit natürlich hier auch verfolgt haben.
Dass das FBI seinen eigenen ja verschlüsselten Dienstangeboten hat. Ja? Das war äh dieser Dienst Annum und da hat es äh das FBI hat quasi also eigentlich,
schon eine ziemlich geniale Idee. Die haben halt irgendwelche Handys verkauft äh und haben gesagt, ja,
Es gibt hier ein äh du musst quasi Krimineller sein, um das nutzen zu dürfen. Du musst du musst quasi von anderen Kriminellen empfohlen worden sein oder so und haben,
es wirklich geschafft, dass äh dass das halt von sehr vielen äh Kriminellen genutzt wurde, ähm die von ihren Handelspartnerinnen ja mehr oder weniger dazu gedrängt wurden, hm?
Und äh ja äh dieses das haben halt reingeschrieben, wer verschlüsselt war's aber gar nicht, ja. Und äh oder zumindest nicht wirksam verschlüsselt,
Und jetzt gab's aber natürlich ein Problem oder die juristische Frage, ob denn diese,
dadurch gewonnenen ähm Einsichten, Beweismittel vor Gericht verwertbar sind. Das Landgericht Frankfurt,
hat jetzt gesagt, ja ja nee, das ist schon als Beweis verwertbar, denn äh da gab es äh also geht es um ein Verfahren gegen ein hm gegen mutmaßliche Betreiber dreier
Hanfplantagen
und die Vorsitzende Richterin hat gesagt, dass nach ihrer vorläufigen Einschätzung äh liegt jetzt hier kein Beweisverwertungsverbot vor. Äh das ist eine schlechte Nachricht für alle äh,
die diese äh Geräte genutzt haben. Ja und zum Beispiel Pflanzenplantagen betrieben haben oder so was.
Ich finde das so superwitzig, dass wir anscheinend in der Organisierten Kriminalität genauso wenig digital Kompetenz haben wie in der Verwaltung.
Also in diesem Bereich, die sind, das ist ja sind ja auch ähnliche.
Was gemacht da muss man was die müssen mehr bezahlen.
Sind ja auch ähnlich verschworene Gemeinschaften, sagen wir mal, ja.
Ja, mhm.
Ähm aber äh tatsächlich klar, die haben einen hohen Bedarf an äh an diesen Tools und ähm tja ähm.
Ich hätte ich würde niemandem raten äh.
Tools zu benutzen, die die die sich an konkrete Zielgruppen richten, um das mal so,
vorsichtig zu sagen, weil selbst wenn das Ding sicher gewesen wäre, wäre halt so ein Handy in der Tasche äh oder der dessen Traffic in deiner TKÜ halt schon mal ein sehr äh sehr ungünstiges Zeichen, ne.
Na ja.
Äh Telegram wird erstmal nicht abgeschaltet. Nancy Fäser hatte das ja zu Beginn relativ früh mal angesagt, dass es jetzt irgendwie äh äh dass sie bereit wäre äh Telegram halt ähm,
abzuschalten.
Und da wurde sie jetzt nochmal nachgefragt und sagte dann gegenüber dem hessischen Rundfunk. Es ist natürlich nicht mein Ziel, das abzuschalten. Aber es sei ihr mal darum gegangen, den äh Druck zu erhöhen. Ja ähm also,
HR Info hat sie gesagt, da ging es also darum, die Gangart zu verschärfen, um zu erreichen, dass der Dienst tätig wird, wenn es um Morddrohungen, Hass und Hetze geht. Ähm ja.
Das hat bestimmt Schockwellen nach Dubai äh gesendet.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Telegram jetzt umso dringender daran arbeitet also das ist ähm bei aller äh Liebe, wir haben dieses Thema ja vor einigen Wochen halt auch schon gesprochen. Hm.
Welche Möglichkeiten es denn da gäbe und warum die alle nicht funktionieren und das Telegram eben natürlich im Gegensatz zu, sagen wir mal anum, natürlich eine riesengroße ähm,
friedfertige Nutzungsbasis hat, die halt ne darüber chattet, ab und zu mal Kokstaxi bestellt und ansonsten irgendwie total friedfertige Leute sind.
Äh die auch geimpft sind zum Beispiel und überhaupt nicht zum Mord von irgendwelchen Politikern aufrufen. Äh die kann Telegramm natürlich hier äh gut
ins Feld führen, ähm wenn hier eine Sperrung äh ins Hause stünde. Das ist insgesamt eine unschöne ähm.
Unschöne Auseinandersetzungen, ne. Äh die hier stattfindet. Ähm,
aber da sei eben auf die Folge mit Max Hoppenstedt verwiesen, wo wir äh das schon vertieft haben. Und dann gibt's noch eine äh schöne Nachricht. Äh Ad Blocker verstoßen nicht gegen Urheberrecht.
Äh hat ausgerechnet äh äh das Landgericht Hamburg festgestellt, ja ähm,
dass bei uns ja schon öfter angesprochen wurde, also wenn du wenn du einen Urheberrechtsfall äh gewinnen möchtest als Urheber, dann gehst du ans Landgericht Hamburg.
Und das hat der Axel-Springer-Verlag versucht ähm.
Die wollten den Einsatz von Adblockern auf den,
Angeboten ihres Verlages untersagen und ähm zwar haben sie gesagt, das wäre die Verletzung,
Es es fände die Verletzung ihres Urheberrechts statt, weil ja irisch ihr geschaffenes Objekt die Webseite.
Verändert wird. Und Sie haben ja schließlich das Urheberrecht daran,
interessant äh also warum sind sie zu den Hamburger Richtern gegangen, weil die vor einiger Zeit mal entschieden haben, dass Cheating, also die Umarbeitung des Programmes, des Spielprogrammes im Arbeitsspeicher,
Äh verboten werden kann durch die Urheber. Also die sagen, ich bin der Urheber dieses Spiels, Counter-Strike, haste nicht gesehen und jetzt geht einer hin und macht ein Programm, was äh,
Im Arbeitsspeicher etwas an dieser an meinem Werk ändert, dann ist mein Urheberrecht verletzt und deswegen dürfen Cheater,
tue es nicht vertrieben werden. Und da hat Hamburg gesagt, ihr sicher, Urheberrecht, klar. Und,
daran anknüpfen, hat jetzt also der Axel Springer Verlag versucht zu sagen, dieses Bild DE ist unser Werk will ihn ja auch niemals strittig machen.
Und da gehören aber äh diese Veränderungen verletzen daher unser Urheberrecht und da haben Sie in äh selbst in,
Hamburg niemanden von überzeugen können. Die haben halt gesagt, ja klar, der Adblocker greift in die Darstellung urheberrechtlich geschützter Inhalte ein, aber das ausblenden oder überschreiben einzelner CSS-Elemente stellt dabei jetzt keine,
Umarbeitung nach Paragraf 69 C des Urheberrechts dar, denn die Übertragung hatte im L-Daten werden ja nicht verändert, sondern nur einige,
Datenstrukturen anders dargestellt als beabsichtigt und deswegen sind also Adbblocker kein Verstoß gegen das Urheberrecht. Ich glaube, dass das,
dass das nicht so sein kann, äh war allen klar, die Meldung ist deshalb spannend, weil's selbst das Landgericht Hamburg verstanden hat.
Okay, das muss ich mir echt noch mal anschauen, weil also das ist ja wirklich auch eine interessante Argumentation, ne. Melde mich jetzt auch nicht äh verwundert, wenn die Richter da nach Hamburg sich zumindest dieser,
Argumentation gegenüber offen gezeigt äh hätten ein Stück weit, wenn sie vielleicht auch zu einer anderen.
Sie haben's ja offenbar zugelassen. Insofern äh also Sie haben da ja äh wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ein Urteil äh gefällt oder eine begründete Abweisung der Klage verfasst. Ähm.
Allerdings schreibt äh Thorsten Kleins war der äh Autor des Artikels glaube ich ja genau. Thorsten hat den Gefühl. Äh das letzte Wort ist in der Angelegenheit äh noch nicht äh gesprochen, weil ähm.
Die Kläger, also ähm der äh Axel-Springer-Verlag jetzt seine ähm,
äh eine äh also unterschiedliche Strategien führt, ne. Wir haben äh wir erinnern uns daran, dass äh AdBlock,
das Unternehmen, das eben dieses AdBlock Plus macht ein Programm hat was acceptable Ads heißt, wo sie im Prinzip sagen, wir haben eine White List,
Und wer da drauf kommen möchte als Werbetreibender muss an uns bezahlen.
Und das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt das feinste Geschäftsmodell zu sagen, unser Produkt sperrt Werbung. Es sei denn, du bezahlst uns, ja? Aber ähm,
also auch dagegen hatte ähm der Axel äh Springer Verlag äh sich äh gewehrt,
oder mehrere Verlage. Äh darunter, Axel Springer und da hat aber auch die äh haben die Bundesrichter gesagt, na ja, äh also vom Bundesgerichtshof, nö, das ist schon in Ordnung, dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Interessant.
Das ist wirklich interessant. Vor allem diese äh diese Behauptung.
Die Werbung wäre jetzt Teil ihrer Urheberschaft, sicher auch bemerkenswert, ja, also als das ist ja nun nachweislich Sirparty.
Ja, also mindestens der der des Unternehmens, was da wirbt oder welche Organisation auch immer, äh oder dann mittelbar zumindest der Werbeagentur oder wer auch immer damit konkret betraut ist, aber es ist ja nicht in dem eigentlichen Sinne eine Urheberrechtliche Tätigkeit äh äh
äh in diese Werbung selbst reingeflossen, bleibt
quasi noch die Inanspruchnahme der Urheberrechtschaft am layout. Das ist ja letzten Endes das, was Sie meinen, ne?
Wie gesagt, das Interessante an der Meldung ist, dass das sogar das Landgericht Hamburg verstanden hat.
Na ja gut, also zumindest bisher, ne? Also es es versuche nur gerade so ein bisschen diese diese Argumentation nachzuvollziehen, wo wo
worauf sie jetzt das Urheberrecht schon wieder loslassen wollen, nachdem wir schon so viele Fälle gehabt haben bis hin zu den Behörden, wenn sie auf ähm,
Informationsanfragen, äh antworten und sagen, ja nee hier wie ihr wollt unsere PDFs sehen, da ist ja Urheberrecht drauf so, nach dem Motto ja hier Abhörprotokolle dürfen nicht äh angeschaut werden, weil es ja mein Urheberrecht drauf, ne.
Ja äh es ist skurril, aber äh also Axel Springer will jetzt gegen das Urteil Rechtsmittel einlegen.
Ähm mit dieser Argumentation haben sie,
2018 vom Oberlandesgericht in Hamburg äh den iPhone at Blocker at Mob schon platt gemacht. Ja also die haben die sagen ja ja gut lass das Landgericht mal äh labern,
Wir hatten schon mal Erfolg vorm Oberlandesgericht Hamburg und äh da wollen sie dann als nächstes hin. Also da ist das letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen. Das ist noch nicht durchgeurteilt.
Klingt nach was was mal beim BGH äh landen kann.
Werden wir sehen.
Wenn der Axel-Springer-Verlag sich in seinen Rechten verletzt zieht, dann äh wird er ja ganz ganz empfindlich.
Müssen alle alle Ressourcen müssen.
Ganz empfindlich sind die da.
Jo, das wäre dann noch so ein bisschen der äh äh so die die anderen Dinge, die geschehen sind. Damit können wir glaube ich den Sack jetzt zumachen und es nochmal herzlich bei Lillit bedanken, ne.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ich da sein durfte. War sehr witzig.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ich meine, mit so einem Content kannst du ja immer kommen. Das ist das unterstreicht den äh eine Entertainment-Anspruch dieses Produkts hier.
Super,
Ja dann wünschen wir euch äh wünschen wir dir noch viel Erfolg bei äh dem was du da noch so äh äh betreibst. Wie haben Sie den Eindruck, die Ideen gehen ja nicht aus. Ich merke auch äh langsam wieder so ein bisschen so wie wie sehr mir dann doch irgendwie der Kongress
äh fehlt so, weil einfach so als Ort
äh all dieser ganze Wahnsinn äh auch äh jeglich immer jährlich auch immer wieder neu durchgerührt wird so, dass dass ja, das braucht's jetzt dann bald
auch mal langsam wieder. Aber Pandemie ist ja bald vorbei, dann äh wird das.
Ich hätte noch eine, ich hätte noch eine Frage Lilit und zwar habe ich hier gerade mal bei Apple geguckt, diese äh Air-Tags, ne? Ähm wenn man die kaufen möchte, äh die gibt's entweder einzeln oder im Viererpack.
Ähm hast du einen Viererpack gekauft oder ein einzelnes?
Drei noch.
Drei gibt's noch. Okay, alles klar. Dann können wir uns also.
Man weiß ja nicht, auf was man noch so stößt.
Ja, das dachte ich auch so. Und einer ist mir schon mal kaputt gegangen und dann dachte ich so, hm.
Tja, okay, gut.
Alles klar. Dann damit ist die Frage beantwortet. Vielen Dank.
Okay, danke Lille. Danke an alle äh fürs Zuhören und ähm ja wir sagen erstmal tschüss, bis bald.
Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.